It's hockey season, and you can get anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. Well, almost, almost anything. So no, you can't get an ice rink on Uber Eats. But iced tea, ice cream, or just plain old ice? Yes, we deliver those. Goaltenders, no. But chicken tenders, yes. Because those are groceries, and we deliver those too.
现在是冰球赛季，你可以通过 Uber Eats 配送所需的一切。好吧，几乎，几乎是一切。所以不，你无法在 Uber Eats 上买到溜冰场。但冰茶、冰淇淋，或者只是普通的老冰块？是的，我们配送这些。守门员，不。但鸡柳，是的。因为那些是杂货，我们也配送那些。
Along with your favorite restaurant food, alcohol, and other everyday essentials. Order Uber Eats now. For alcohol, you must be legal drinking age. Please enjoy responsibly. Product availability varies by region. See app for details. When it comes to Smart Water Alkaline 9.5 plus pH with antioxidant, there's nothing to overthink. So, while you may be performing mental gymnastics over whether the post-work gym crowd is worth it, if you'll be able to find a spot for your yoga mat, or if that spin instructor will make you late for dinner again. Don't overthink how you hydrate. Life's full of choices. Smart Water Alkaline is
还有你最喜欢的餐厅食物、酒类和其他日常必需品。立即订购 Uber Eats。对于酒类，您必须达到法定饮酒年龄。请理性享用。产品供应情况因地区而异。详情请见应用程序。说到含有抗氧化剂的 Smart Water 碱性 9.5 加 pH 水，没有什么可过度思考的。因此，虽然你可能会对下班后的健身房人群是否值得、是否能为你的瑜伽垫找到位置、或者动感单车教练是否会让你再次晚餐迟到进行心理体操。不要对如何补水过度思考。生活充满了选择。Smart Water 碱性水是
a simple one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
一个简单的选择。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office ladies. Hello. Happy finale part two. This is really it. This is season nine, episode twenty seven, written by Greg Daniels, directed by Ken Quapus. Would you like a summary? I would.
我们是办公室女士。你好。大结局第二部分快乐。这真的是结局了。这是第九季第二十七集，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·克瓦普斯导演。你想要一个总结吗？我想要。
All right. Dwight and Angela are getting married. Kelly and Ryan are going to reunite. Nellie gets the baby she's been hoping for. Pam and Jim make a very big decision about their future. And everyone at Dunder Mifflin gathers for one last night together. And this, you guys, remember when Greg asked us all what we hoped for our characters? Mine was, I hoped that Angela and Dwight would end up together. So I love watching this, it's so awesome.
好的。德怀特和安吉拉要结婚了。凯莉和瑞恩要复合了。内莉得到了她一直期盼的宝宝。帕姆和吉姆对他们的未来做出了一个非常重大的决定。邓德米夫林的每个人都聚集在一起，共度最后一个夜晚。大家还记得格雷格问我们每个人对角色的期望是什么时候吗？我的是，我希望安吉拉和德怀特最终能走到一起。所以我很喜欢看这个，太棒了。
It's so perfect. Well, fast fact number one, Angela is your look back moment. All right, this is our final look back. You know, this is the bonus feature on disc four for season nine. And when I was watching all of it, one of the things that really stood out to me was when everyone reflected on what the writers meant to the show and what Greg Daniels meant to everyone. Let's listen. First and foremost, it's a writer's show and we really owe everything to the writers on this. We also owe the writers and especially Greg Daniels a big debt of gratitude
太完美了。好吧，趣味事实一，安吉拉是你的回顾时刻。好的，这是我们的最后一次回顾。你知道的，这是第九季第四张光盘上的花絮。当我观看所有这些内容时，其中一件事让我印象深刻，那就是当每个人反思编剧对这部剧的意义以及格雷格·丹尼尔斯对每个人的意义时。让我们听听。首先，这是一部编剧主导的剧集，我们真的欠这部剧的编剧一切。我们同样欠编剧们，尤其是格雷格·丹尼尔斯巨幅的感激之情
in that they trust the actors enough to let us play with their lines and improvise off of them and come up with other line ideas and pitches. You don't get to do that on a lot of other TV shows. I think what helped it push through was a phenomenal cast and really great writing staff. The perfect man for the job in Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels said in our first meeting, he's like, you know, American comedy is like this big ship, you know, a big like cruise liner. And if you can just point it one degree in the right direction, you can make a big, big difference but you can't turn comedy that sharply and I feel like that's what The Office did is it took
因为他们足够信任演员，让我们能够演绎他们的台词并在其中即兴发挥，并提出其他台词想法和创意。你在很多其他电视剧里是做不到这一点的。我认为帮助它脱颖而出的是出色的演员阵容和非常棒的编剧团队。格雷格·丹尼尔斯是这项工作的完美人选。格雷格·丹尼尔斯在我们的第一次会议上说，你知道，美国喜剧就像这艘大船，你知道的，一艘大邮轮。如果你能把它朝正确的方向引导一度，你就能产生巨大、巨大的影响，但你不能把喜剧转变得那么急剧，我觉得这就是《办公室》所做的，它把
American comedy and it turned it one degree in the right direction. At the time comedy was very silly and there were a lot of very broad shows on the air and it was just the perfect time for reality to hit comedy. I think that there's something sort of like it was lightning in a bottle for the entire cast and the entire creative team. It's kind of a troupe of people who understand writing and performing all at the same time. I spent more time here than I did on the set. I spent more time here than I did at home. I definitely spent more hours here over the past 10 years than anywhere else in the world. And it's not a very pretty place to be, but there was a lot of laughter and a lot of great ideas.
美国喜剧朝正确的方向扭转了一度。当时喜剧非常愚蠢，播出的节目有很多非常粗俗的，这正是现实冲击喜剧的完美时机。我认为某种程度上，这对于整个演员阵容和整个创意团队来说，就像是瓶中闪电。这就像是一群同时理解编剧和表演的人。我在这里度过的时间比在片场的时间还要长。我在这里度过的时间比在家里的时间还要长。过去10年里，我在这里度过的小时数绝对比世界上任何地方都多。这不是一个非常漂亮的地方，但这里有很多笑声和很多伟大的想法。
Well, Greg really was the visionary behind this show. It was not an easy thing to adapt something that was only 13 episodes long, but a brilliant concept, and turn it into this 201 episodes of American television. I mean, that was Greg. Yeah. And also our writers. He assembled such an amazing team. And you know, as Jen and I have done this rewatch, those of you that listen know how gracious the writing staff has been and Greg, they've come on this show,
嗯，格雷格确实是这部剧背后的远见卓识者。改编一部只有13集但概念极其出色的作品，并将其变成201集的美国电视节目，这绝非易事。我的意思是，那是格雷格。是的。还有我们的编剧。他组建了这样一个出色的团队。你知道，正如珍娜和我一直在做这个重温一样，那些收听的听众知道编剧团队和格雷格有多亲切，他们来到了这个节目，
they have sent us an answers and audio clips and we're just so appreciative to them. Well, Lady, you shared in our book that you had a writing professor who said, if something is a pleasure to do, it's a pleasure to watch. And I think that's what BJ was saying in that clip. Like, it was my pleasure to sit in this dumpy writer's room for 10 years.
他们给我们发送了答案和音频剪辑，我们对此非常感激。嗯，女士，你在我们的书中分享过，你有一位写作教授曾说过，如果一件事做起来是一种快乐，那么看它也是一种快乐。我想这就是 BJ 在那个剪辑中所说的。就像，坐在长达10年破烂的编剧室里是我的荣幸。
If you watch it on the DVD, he is in the writer's room and there's not much there, you know? But it is true. We just all had such a joyful time doing this show and I think people feel it when they watch it. Yeah. Well, Angela, I loved your look-backs. Thanks. I enjoyed watching that. I couldn't watch it, everybody.
如果你在 DVD 上看它，他在编剧室里，那里其实没多少东西，你知道吗？但这是真的。我们大家在制作这部剧时都度过了非常欢乐的时光，我想人们在观看时能感受到这一点。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我喜欢你的回顾。谢谢。我很享受观看那个。我没法看，各位。
I told Angela, I'm like, I'll be a puddle. I can't do it. I said, Jenna, do you want to watch it together? And you were just like, no. Well, I was a puddle. So yeah. I'll say I haven't watched the finale until we had to watch it to break it down.
我告诉安吉拉，我说，我会变成一滩眼泪。我做不到。我说，安吉拉，你想一起看吗？而你只是说，不。好吧，我成了一滩眼泪。所以是的。我得说，直到我们为了剖析它而不得不观看大结局之前，我都没有看过它。
Because I don't know if this is true, and I actually wish we would have asked Billie Eilish this. I know some people who will watch the whole series, but they won't watch the finale. Oh man. They're missing some really good nuggets. I know, I know and actually I'm glad now that I've seen it. But yeah. Well I'll tell you what I did after I watched the look back and I recommend that you do this because it's
因为我不知道这是否属实，我其实希望我们曾问过比莉·艾利什这个问题。我认识一些人，他们会看完整部剧，但不会看大结局。哦天哪。他们错失了一些非常精彩的亮点。我知道，我知道，其实我现在很高兴我看了。但是，好吧。我会告诉你我在看完美回顾后做了什么，我建议你也这样做，因为这
really emotional. I then watched the season 9 bloopers. Oh no! And then I was just laughing. So I went from tearing up to laughter and that's the way you gotta do it. All right, well let's move on to fast fact number two. I'm calling this one, wedding weather. Yeah. We shot all of Angela and Dwight's wedding at Big Sky Ranch.
真的很感人。然后我看了第九季的幕后花絮。哦不！然后我就只是在大笑。所以我从热泪盈眶转变为开怀大笑，这就是你必须要做的。好吧，让我们继续看趣味事实二。我把这个叫做，婚礼天气。是的。我们在大天际牧场拍摄了安吉拉和德怀特的所有婚礼镜头。
We shot for three days at the ranch. We shot on a Thursday, a Friday, and a Sunday. Thursday was actually my birthday. Oh yeah, that's right. It was also the day Steve was there. Oh, so that was a really, really fun memory for me from that birthday. But there was an issue.
我们在牧场拍摄了三天。我们在星期四、星期五和星期天进行了拍摄。星期四实际上是我的生日。哦对，没错。那也是史蒂夫在那里的日子。哦，所以对我来说那是那个生日的一个非常非常有趣的记忆。但有一个问题。
Like any real wedding, we couldn't control the weather and it was crazy windy. It was cold. It rained. The high was 61. The low was 45. Yeah. I remember them being worried the tent would blow away.
就像任何真正的婚礼一样，我们无法控制天气，而且风大得离谱。天气很冷。下雨了。最高温度是61华氏度。最低是45华氏度。是的。我记得他们担心帐篷会被风吹走。
They were waiting it down. The lanterns were swaying. You saw the cloud bank rolling in. Well I remember wondering, are we able to shoot this? Yeah. Because the sky was very, very gloomy and ominous, and Matt Stone actually had to put up all these giant lights and like floodlights in order to try to brighten up everything.
他们在用重物压住它。灯笼在摇晃。你看到云层翻滚而来了。嗯，我记得当时在想，我们还能拍吗？是的。因为天空非常非常阴暗和不祥，马特·石实际上不得不设置所有这些巨大的灯光和类似探照灯的设备，试图让所有东西变亮。
It was. Yeah. But the call sheets for these three days, they said, we will shoot rain or shine. Please be prepared. Yep. And we have some great, great pictures that really showcase the windy conditions. I mean, I have one of the clouds rolling in. I don't know if you remember, Jenna, but my veil kept blowing all over my face. I do. I have a picture of me and John and the veil is about to wrap around us. But our favorite, hands down, is a photo we discovered when we wrote our book, The Office
确实。是的。但这三天的通告单上写着，无论风雨无阻，我们都会拍摄。请做好准备。是的。我们有一些非常棒的照片，真正展示了大风的天气条件。我的意思是，我有一张云层翻滚进来的照片。我不知道你是否还记得，珍娜，但我的头纱一直被吹到脸上。我记得。我有一张我和约翰的照片，头纱快要把我们包裹进去了。但我们最喜欢的，毫无疑问是我们写书《办公室》时发现的一张照片
BFFs. Yeah. I took the picture standing in Angela Martin's shallow grave of everyone looking back at me. I really wanted to remember what I saw on Angela's wedding day. And I took that picture and I never thought anything about it. You know, we looked at it, I put it in a scrapbook.
BFF。是的。我站在安吉拉·马丁的浅墓里拍了这张照片，照片里每个人都在回头看我。我真的很想记住我在安吉拉婚礼那天看到的东西。我拍了那张照片，从没多想。你知道的，我们看了看它，我把它放进了剪贴簿。
But when we started to do our book, we were really zooming in on pictures to make sure the image was good, the quality was good. And Catherine. It's so funny. It was, I can't believe we didn't see it for years. I know. Catherine, in this picture, everyone looks cold.
但当我们开始写书时，我们真的在放大照片，以确保图像质量好，质量过关。还有凯瑟琳。太搞笑了。真的是，我不敢相信我们多年都没看到它。我知道。凯瑟琳，在这张照片里，每个人看起来都很冷。
Jenna, you look freezing. Yeah. Kate Flannery is actually doing a thing with her face like, ooh. But Catherine's face is completely covered by her hair. Yeah. It's hilarious. We'll put it in stories. I also found in my digital clutter an email from our key second assistant director Stephanie. Oh my gosh I was just texting with Stephanie recently. I love her.
珍娜，你看上去冻僵了。是的。凯特·弗兰纳里实际上在做着一个“噢”的表情。但凯瑟琳的脸完全被头发遮住了。是的。太搞笑了。我们会把它放到动态里。我还从我的数字杂乱中找到了一封来自我们的主要第二副导演斯蒂芬妮的电子邮件。哦天哪，我最近刚和斯蒂芬妮发过短信。我爱她。
Remember I told you I went to that birthday party where we discussed whether or not the birthday boy was right? Right. Okay. Show her, grow her. Right. So I thought oh the morning not the birthday boy was right. Okay, show her a grower. Right. So I thought, oh, the morning after the birthday party, I'm gonna send a fun text to all the ladies about some inside joke from the party. So I send it to my friends, Michelle, Ann, and Steph. Oh no, you texted the wrong Stephanie.
还记得我跟你说过我去那个生日派对吗，我们在那里讨论寿星是不是正确的？对。好吧，成长她，成长她。对。所以我想，哦，生日派对的第二天早上，我要给所有女士发一条有趣的短信，关于派对上的某个内部笑话。所以我把它发给了我的朋友们，米歇尔、安和斯蒂夫。哦不，你发错斯蒂芬妮了。
Texted the wrong Stephanie. And so Steph, our second AD, after a while of us not hearing from Steph, who was at the party, she texts back, hey, ladies, this sounds like a really fun party. Oh, no. But I think you mean this for a different Steph. Oh, no. But anyway, and then I was like texting her on the side and was like, how are you though? All right, so go ahead.
发错了斯蒂芬妮。所以斯蒂芬妮，我们的第二副导演，在我们长时间没有听到斯蒂芬妮（她当时在派对上）的消息后，她回短信说，嘿，女士们，这听起来像是一个非常有趣的派对。哦，不。但我想你是发给另一个斯蒂夫的。哦，不。不过无论如何，然后我私下给她发短信说，不过你最近怎么样？好了，继续吧。
Steph sent an email. She did. It was to the entire cast and here's what it said. Hey guys, I'm looking forward to the giant days we have coming up. They should be a lot of fun. I am trying to make the days run as smoothly as possible and want to alert you to our plans in advance. Due to the nature of the set
斯蒂芬妮发了一封电子邮件。她确实发了。那是发给全体演员的，内容如下：嘿，各位，我很期待即将到来的重大拍摄日。它们应该会非常有趣。我正在努力让这些天尽可能顺利地进行，并想提前向你们通告我们的计划。由于片场的性质
and the gorgeous views at the location, there is very little indoor space available to us. We are planning to take advantage of the remoteness of the set and we will see 360. Oh, I remember this. Yeah, so that meant we do not have any holding areas planned. Yes, there were no trailers up there. The trailers were down this long hill.
和该地点的壮丽景色，留给我们的室内空间非常有限。我们正计划利用片场的偏远性，我们将进行全景拍摄。哦，我记得这个。是的，这意味着我们没有计划任何候场区。是的，那上面没有拖车。拖车在那座长长的小山下面。
You had to take a van. Uh-huh. So once we got ready at the bottom of the hill, you would take a van up to the top. Yep. And then you were just at this wedding. Right. Stephanie said, while we're shooting, there will be a small group of you who are working inside the house. This is a hot set, please don't move anything around.
你得坐面包车。嗯哼。所以一旦我们在山底准备好，你就会坐面包车去山顶。是的。然后你就在这个婚礼现场了。对。斯蒂芬妮说，在我们拍摄期间，会有一小部分人在房子里面工作。这是一个热拍现场，请不要移动任何东西。
So we were inside that house, Dwight's farmhouse. The other thing I wanted to note is she wrote, there are 33 principal actors working today. And 50 background performers. Yep, she wrote, we are preparing for rain. And lastly, please be aware that there is no cell phone service. My cell phone has not been working at this location. Production is renting a temporary cell phone. Please try me by that or email me. We were
所以我们在那栋房子里，德怀特的农舍。我想指出的另一件事是她写道，今天有33位主演在工作。还有50位群众演员。是的，她写道，我们正在为下雨做准备。最后，请注意这里没有手机信号。我的手机在这个地点一直没有信号。剧组租了一个临时手机。请通过那个联系我或发电子邮件。我们
really in the middle of nowhere. She included directions which were very detailed. And I remember that drive, don't you, Jenna? In the morning, it was full fog and mist. And we were driving. You would have thought we were sort of like in the highlands of Scotland. Yes, very much. That's a great comparison.
真的是在荒郊野岭。她附上了非常详细的路线说明。我记得那段车程，你不记得吗，珍娜？清晨，到处都是浓雾和薄雾。我们在开车。你会以为我们身处苏格兰高地呢。是的，非常像。这是一个很好的比较。
We had to go through two different canyons. Well, I think that these conditions actually lent themselves to a really, really fun final shoot experience. It really reminded me of our early days on set when none of us had phones or working computers. And we just would sit on set. And hang out. And that's what we did when we shot this wedding.
我们不得不穿过两个不同的峡谷。嗯，我认为这些条件实际上促成了一次非常非常有趣的最终拍摄体验。这真的让我想起了我们在片场早期的日子，当时我们都没有手机或能用的电脑。我们只会坐在片场。闲逛。我们在拍这场婚礼时就是这么做的。
We just hung out. And it was really fun. We hung out in parkas that had a piece of tape with our name on it. That's how we knew which parka was ours. It was super cold. So cold. And we just huddled up in that drafty house
我们只是闲逛。我们穿着印有写着我们名字的胶带的派克大衣闲逛。这就是我们如何知道哪件派克大衣是我们的。超级冷。太冷了。我们就挤在那栋四面透风的房子里
and talked and laughed. And it was great. All right. This is a big top of show everybody. And I've got a big fast fact three. Yeah. Because we had a big guest of show everybody, and I've got a big fast fact three. Yeah. Because we had a big guest star on this episode. Mr. Steve Carell.
聊天大笑。太棒了。好了。这是每个人都知道的节目大开场。我有一个重磅趣味事实三。是的。因为我们在这集里有一个重磅客串明星，各位，我有一个重磅趣味事实三。是的。因为我们在这集里有一个重磅客串明星。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔先生。
I still can't believe how they pulled this off. I really can't. We got a lot of fan mail about it. And I have a whole breakdown on how we made it work. Let's get into these fan questions. Bailey E. from Manitoba said, one of the scenes from The Office that never fails to make me cry is when Michael comes back to be Dwight's best man. I've always wondered whose idea was
我至今仍不敢相信他们是怎么做到的。真的不敢相信。我们收到了很多关于此事的粉丝来信。我有一份关于我们如何使其奏效的完整剖析。让我们进入这些粉丝提问吧。来自曼尼托巴省的贝利·E说，《办公室》中总能让我哭泣的场景之一，就是迈克尔回来担任德怀特的伴郎。我一直想知道是谁的主意
it to have Steve Carell come back and was it a surprise to the cast? And Megan Kay from Tampa, Florida said, I'd love to know your ladies feelings on Steve coming back to the set. In the opening credits, his name is not mentioned. So it was a huge surprise for viewers to see. I absolutely ball every time I see it and I would love to know how it all came together. And Hugo S from Kyoto, Japan said,
让史蒂夫·卡瑞尔回来，这对演员来说是个惊喜吗？来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的梅根·K说，我很想知道女士们对史蒂夫重返片场的感受。在开场职员表中，没有提到他的名字。所以对于观众来说，看到他是一个巨大的惊喜。每次看到这一幕我都哭得稀里哗啦，我很想知道这一切是如何促成的。来自日本京都的雨果·S说，
what was the process in getting Steve to return for his final episode? Well, Jenna, you know everything that was happening behind the scenes that the rest of us didn't know, so you have to share. All right, well it was Greg's idea to have Steve come back. He had wanted that for a very long time and he asked him pretty early in season 9. But Steve was reluctant. He felt like Michael's story had really ended. He didn't want to open it back up again. And he especially did not want to come back after two years and have this finale episode be about him.
让史蒂夫回归拍摄他的最后一集的流程是什么？好吧，珍娜，你知道幕后发生的所有其他人不知道的事情，所以你必须分享一下。好吧，让史蒂夫回来是格雷格的主意。他很早就想这么做了，并在第九季初就问过他。但史蒂夫很勉强。他觉得迈克尔的故事真的已经结束了。他不想再次重启它。他尤其不想在两年后回来，让这个大结局集全围绕着他展开。
Steve really felt like my character had his ending. This is everybody else's ending. And he didn't want to overshadow that. Well, he's very gracious that way. Yeah. But then Greg had the idea of the final episode being Dwight and Angela's wedding. And Steve agreed Michael would be there.
史蒂夫真的觉得我的角色已经有了他的结局。这是其他所有人的结局。他不想喧宾夺主。嗯，他在这方面非常体贴。是的。但随后格雷格有了个主意，最后一集是德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼。史蒂夫同意迈克尔会在那里。
I believe that. I believe Michael would want to be there for Dwight and Angela. Yeah, it was a creative reason that was supported by history, you know? So I remember being up in the writer's room with John when we found out that Steve was going to come back and we were sworn to secrecy.
我相信这一点。我相信迈克尔会想去参加德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼。是的，这是一个有历史依据的创作原因，你知道吗？所以当我和约翰在编剧室得知史蒂夫要回来时，我们发誓要保守秘密。
This was like really epic to pull off. I've told this story before. Rainn Wilson turned to me and he said, not even Angela, Jenna. I was like, okay. So aggressive. I mean, he knows I tell you everything. I know. It was really hard not to tell you.
要实现这一点真的很震撼。我以前讲过这个故事。雷恩·威尔逊转向我，他说，连安吉拉都没有，珍娜。我当时想，好吧。太咄咄逼人了。我的意思是，他知道我什么都告诉你。我知道。很难不告诉你。
Because, Angie, you did not find out until he showed up on set that day. I know the exact moment. I had driven through the two canyons, I had taken the dirt road. I was at our base camp in the middle of nowhere. It was cold and foggy. And right as I was getting to hair and makeup, the set PA turned to me and said, Oh, Steve is here. And I said, what are you talking about? And at first I thought she meant Steve Burgess.
因为，安吉，直到那天他出现在片场，你才知道。我记得确切的时刻。我穿过了两个峡谷，走过了土路。我在前线基地，处于荒郊野岭之中。天气又冷又雾。就在我走向化妆间时，片场制片助理转过身对我说：“哦，史蒂夫来了。”我说：“你在说什么？”起初我以为她指的是史蒂夫·伯吉斯。
And she was like, Steve Carell is here. I said, what? And I opened the door and there he was. He was sitting in hair and makeup. And I just was like, Steve. I was like, oh my gosh. And I just hugged him and we were laughing. I couldn't believe it.
然后她说：“史蒂夫·卡瑞尔来了。”我说：“什么？”我打开门，他就在那儿。他坐在化妆椅上。我当时就想：“史蒂夫。”我心想：“哦天哪。”我只是拥抱了他，我们在大笑。我简直不敢相信。
I was like so confused. And then we just got to chat in hair and makeup and it was absolutely wonderful. I remember the vibe in the hair and makeup trailer when he was in there. Buzz, buzzing. Yeah, a body buzz. Everybody was like, it was a party.
我当时糊涂极了。然后我们在化妆间聊天，绝对是太棒了。我记得他在化妆拖车里时那里的氛围。嗡嗡作响，嗡嗡作响。是的，身体都在嗡嗡作响。每个人都像是在参加派对。
Yeah. Well, this was really crazy because Greg did not tell NBC that Steve was coming back. Well, this is what I remember at the table read when all the NBC suits were there, all the executives. In the script, it was Creed, right? Yes. So that's the thing.
是的。嗯，这真的很疯狂，因为格雷格没有告诉 NBC 史蒂夫要回来。好吧，这是我在剧本围读时记得的事情，当时所有 NBC 的高管都在场，所有的管理层都在。在剧本里，那是克里德，对吧？是的。所以这就是问题所在。
When you turn in a script, they use those script pages, those locations, those scenes to set a budget for your episode. And so they had a scene at our table read between Dwight and Jim, but it wasn't the scene that ended up in the show. But there was a scene, it was a placeholder of Jim helping Dwight right before it's time to go to the wedding. Same number of lines, same page count as the real scene with Steve. And then later, Michael has a
当你交出剧本时，他们会使用这些剧本页数、这些拍摄地点、这些场景来为你的剧集设定预算。所以在我们的剧本围读中，德怀特和吉姆之间有一场戏，但那不是最终出现在剧中的戏。但确实有一场戏，那是吉姆在去婚礼前夕帮助德怀特的占位场景。相同的台词数，与史蒂夫的真实场景相同的页数。然后后来，迈克尔有了一段
talking head where he says, oh it's like all my kids grew up and they got married. Creed read that. Yes, at the table read Creed read it. It was a Creed talking head. It got a laugh. It did. So no one at NBC knew. No. And Steve Burgess told me that NBC has a rule that nobody can be filmed for the show without a signed contract. So in order to follow the rules and still keep the secret,
单人访谈，他说，哦，就像我所有的孩子都长大了并结婚了。克里德读了那段。是的，在剧本围读时，克里德读了。那是克里德的单人访谈。引发了一阵笑声。确实如此。所以 NBC 没有人知道。没有。史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，NBC 有一条规定，未经签署的合同，任何人不得为节目进行拍摄。因此，为了遵守规定同时又保守秘密，
Steve Carell signed a contract to do the show for this episode, but Steve Burgess kept it locked in his desk drawer until the day the show aired. Steve Burgess? So he could be like, no, no, no, look at the date. I had a contract. I just forgot to hand it in. This is some serious maneuvering. There's more, lady.
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔签署了一份合同，为本集节目进行拍摄，但史蒂夫·伯吉斯将其锁在办公桌抽屉里，直到节目播出当天。史蒂夫·伯吉斯？这样他就可以说：“不，不，不，看日期。我有一份合同。我只是忘了交上去。”这真是一些严肃的操作。还有更多，女士。
So usually, every day after you shoot, you send those tapes into the studio. They're called the dailies. Right, for them to review if they have something they didn't like, they want to take out, yada yada. They didn't send Steve scenes. They kept them locked up somewhere else. And then Dave Rogers did a cut of the episode
所以通常情况下，每天拍摄结束后，你会把这些磁带送到工作室。它们被称为每日素材。是的，供他们审查是否有他们不喜欢、想要删除的东西，等等，等等。他们没有发送史蒂夫的场景。他们把它们锁在别的地方。然后戴夫·罗杰斯剪辑了这一集
because the network has to give notes, sent a Steve-less version. So there's a lot of people in cahoots here to keep Steve's appearance a secret. And I know Greg had a specific reason. Share it, Jenna. He was afraid that if he turned in any footage of Steve Carell on the show before it aired, that NBC would make promos out of it and ruin the surprise. Oh, they would want the ratings for sure.
因为电视台必须给出意见，所以发送了一个没有史蒂夫的版本。所以这里有很多人串通一气，为了对史蒂夫的出现保密。我知道格雷格有一个具体的原因。分享一下吧，珍娜。他担心如果他在节目播出前交出任何带有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔镜头的素材，NBC 会用它制作宣传片并破坏惊喜。哦，他们肯定会想要收视率的。
Right? Yeah. And then it wouldn't have been a surprise. I get that. So finally we had our final cut, the version that we had to turn into the network. With Steve. With Steve, but we weren't turning it in. And I guess NBC finally put their foot down and said, we will not air something that no
对吧？是的。那样就不会是惊喜了。我懂了。所以最后我们有了最终剪辑版，即我们需要交到电视台的版本。带有史蒂夫。带有史蒂夫，但我们没有上交。我想 NBC 终于态度强硬，并说，我们不会播出任何这里没有人看过的东西。
one here has seen. So Greg and Steve Burgess and Dave Rogers and Claire Scanlon said, you can come stand in our edit bay and watch it. Did that piss him off? I'm sure this never happens. Steve Burgess was like, I'll never work in this town again. Greg was like, it'll be fine.
所以格雷格、史蒂夫·伯吉斯、戴夫·罗杰斯和克莱尔·斯坎伦说，你们可以来我们的剪辑室站着观看。这惹恼他了吗？我敢肯定这从没发生过。史蒂夫·伯吉斯当时想，我再也不会在这个镇上工作了。格雷格说，会没事的。
So Steve Burgess said, you should have seen their faces as they're standing in the edit bay, the day before the episode was gonna air. Were they so grumpy that they had to come to our studios and stand in that edit bay? He said when they saw Steve come on there was this mixture of them being like so pissed and so excited. And Dave Rogers said that they waited until 9 a.m. the day the finale aired to actually hand over the episode. Wow. Is that the greatest kept secret?
所以史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，你应该看看他们在节目播出前一天站在剪辑室里的表情。他们是不是很不高兴，不得不来到我们的工作室并站在那个剪辑室里？他说，当他们看到史蒂夫出现时，那种表情介于非常生气和非常兴奋之间。戴夫·罗杰斯说，他们一直等到大结局播出的那天早上9点才真正交出这一集。哇。这是史上保守得最好的秘密吗？
I mean, yeah. It's gotta be one of the best kept secrets in television. I would have been so stressed. I would have been horrible. But also- I'm so glad I didn't know. I'm so glad. I was so excited when you finally knew. I was like, ah!
我是说，是的。这绝对是电视界保守得最好的秘密之一。我要是知道了，压力会极大。我会表现得很糟糕。但也——我很高兴我不知道。我太高兴了。当你终于知道的时候，我超级兴奋。我当时想，啊！
But I mean, even that, we still had to keep the secret till it aired. Oh yeah. We did so much press, and everybody asked us if Steve was coming back. David Letterman asked John Krasinski if Steve was coming back, and John lied to him. Yeah, lied to his face.
但即便如此，我们仍然必须保守秘密，直到它播出。哦，是的。我们做了大量的媒体宣传，每个人都问我们史蒂夫是否会回来。大卫·莱特曼问约翰·卡拉辛斯基史蒂夫是否会回来，约翰对他撒了谎。是的，当面撒谎。
Lied to David Letterman. David Letterman. No, we were asked tons of questions about the finale, and Greg sent out an email and was like, I need you all to come together and not say a word on this. And we didn't. Mm-hmm. All right.
对大卫·莱特曼撒谎。大卫·莱特曼。不，我们被问了大量关于大结局的问题，格雷格发了一封电子邮件，内容是：我需要你们所有人团结一致，对此守口如瓶。我们做到了。嗯哼。好吧。
Well, like I said, that's a very long top of show, but there was a lot to cover. There was, and there still is a lot to cover. Maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, I brought some show and tell items. I can't wait. It's hockey season, and you can get anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. Well, almost, almost anything. So no, you can't get a nice rank on Uber Eats. But iced tea, ice cream, or just plain old ice? Yes, we deliver those. Goltenders? No. But chicken tenders? Yes.
正如我所说，这是一场非常长的节目开场，但有太多内容需要涵盖。确实如此，而且还有很多内容需要涵盖。也许我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我带来了一些展示和讲述的物品。我等不及了。现在是冰球赛季，你可以通过 Uber Eats 配送所需的一切。好吧，几乎，几乎是一切。所以不，你无法在 Uber Eats 上买到漂亮的溜冰场。但冰茶、冰淇淋，或者只是普通的老冰块？是的，我们配送这些。守门员？不。但鸡柳？是的。
Because those are groceries, and we deliver those too. Along with your favorite restaurant food, alcohol, and other everyday essentials. Order Uber Eats now. For alcohol, you must be legal drinking age. Please enjoy responsibly. Product availability varies by region. See app for details.
因为那些是杂货，我们也配送那些。还有你最喜欢的餐厅食物、酒类和其他日常必需品。立即订购 Uber Eats。对于酒类，您必须达到法定饮酒年龄。请理性享用。产品供应情况因地区而异。详情请见应用程序。
Metrolinx and Crosslinx are reminding everyone to be careful as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so. Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. We are back and we are starting with finale show and tell. Should I be getting my camera out? Sam, Cassie, guess what I brought today? I brought my finale part one and two script. It's the shooting draft that we were given
Metrolinx 和 Crosslinx 提醒大家，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中，请注意安全。请保持警惕，轨道上的列车随时可能通过。请记得遵守所有交通信号。在我们的轨道旁请小心谨慎，且仅在安全的地方进行左转。保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。我们回来了，我们要从大结局展示和讲述开始。我应该把相机拿出来吗？萨姆，卡西，猜猜我今天带来了什么？我带来了我的大结局第一部分和第二部分的剧本。这是我们在
at the table read and I had the entire cast sign it. Wow. Wow, I love that. Isn't that cool? You should frame that. I know, right? This is what I found as I went through my bins of stuff. I had a bin called trailer finale.
剧本围读时收到的拍摄初稿，我让全体演员都在上面签名了。哇。哇，我喜欢这个。不是很酷吗？你应该把它装裱起来。我知道，对吧？这是我在翻找我的物品箱时发现的。我有一个名为“拖车大结局”的箱子。
Oh. Yeah. What's next? What's next is, I'm gonna share one more here and then I have two more that I'll share later in the episode. Okay. So here's the thing I want you all to know about Jenna and I's friendship.
哦。是的。接下来是什么？接下来是，我将在这里分享一个，然后我稍后会在节目中分享另外两个。好的。所以这是我想让你们所有人了解的关于珍娜和我的友谊的一点。
Jenna is a card giver and it's something I love about her. And I have saved all the cards you've ever given me. And you always give me a card that marks a big moment. I am horrible at giving cards. I love to make a gift. I love to buy a gift. But in our friendship, you give cards. And I brought a few. First of all, you gave me a card when we started this podcast. I did?
珍娜是个喜欢送卡片的人，这也是我喜欢她的一点。我保存了你送给我的所有卡片。你总是送我一张标志着重大时刻的卡片。我在送卡片方面糟糕透顶。我喜欢制作礼物。我喜欢购买礼物。但在我们的友谊中，你负责送卡片。我带来了几张。首先，我们在制作这个播客时你送了我一张卡片。我有吗？
Yes. I have no memory of this. And you wrote in it, you said, I have no idea if anyone is gonna listen to us, but I'm just happy I get to do this with my best friend. Such a nice card. You're such a nice card. You're a good card writer. Okay, then I saved the card you gave me at the end of the show when we wrapped the office.
是的。我对此毫无记忆。你在上面写道，你当时说，我不知道是否会有人听我们的节目，但我只是很高兴能和我的好朋友一起做这件事。多么好的一张卡片。你真是个好卡片写手。好吧，我还保留了我们在《办公室》杀青时你送给我的卡片。
Here it is. This is a picture of me coming over the partition. We shared this in our book. This is how you saw me for nine years, just my little tiny head coming over the partition. It shared this in our book. This is how you saw me for nine years, just my little tiny head coming over the partition. It's how I met you. That's right. And you wrote this. And if it's all right, I'm going to read it. Okay.
在这里。这是一张我从隔板后面探出头来的照片。我们在书中分享过这个。这就是你九年来看到我的方式，只有我小小的脑袋从隔板后面探出来。在书中分享了这个。这就是你九年来看到我的方式，只有我小小的脑袋从隔板后面探出来。我就是这样认识你的。没错。你写了这些。如果可以的话，我要读一下。好的。
Angela, it's true what Steve said. No matter what happens with the show, I am so happy to have met you. You have quickly become one of my closest girlfriends, and it is such a gift. At my age, I don't always expect to meet a new person who I could bond with so easily. You are the funniest woman I know. Now it's in writing. And I just love our time together. BFF, Jenna. Well, you are the funniest woman I know. You put it in writing. It's in writing. It's in writing.
安吉拉，史蒂夫说得没错。无论这部节目发生什么，我能认识你我都太高兴了。你很快就成了我最亲密的女性朋友之一，这真是个礼物。到了我这个年纪，我不总是期待能遇到一个能如此轻易建立深厚情谊的新人。你是我认识的最搞笑的女性。现在这可是写下来的。我太喜欢我们在一起的时光了。至交好友，珍娜。嗯，你是我认识的最搞笑的女性。你把它写下来了。写下来了。写下来了。
It's been written down. Anyway, it's one of the things I absolutely love about our friendship is you are great at giving cards and I save them and they mean so much to me. Well, I guess I'm good at giving cards and you're good at saving things. This is true. And that's one of the things I love about you.
已经写下来了。无论如何，我绝对喜欢我们友谊的一点是，你很擅长送卡片，而我很擅长保存东西，它们对我意义重大。好吧，我想我擅长送卡片，而你擅长保存东西。这倒真的。这也是我喜欢你的地方之一。
Well that ends our show and tell right now. Oh, I also want you guys to know I have tons of pictures from this episode. I had brought my camera. I'll be sharing them in stories. But also Steve Burr just sent us so many fantastic behind the scenes pictures from this episode, just like a treasure of pictures. He did. We'll be putting those in stories as well.
好了，我们的展示和讲述就到这里。哦，我还想让你们知道，我有大量来自这一集的照片。我带了我的相机。我会在动态里分享它们。而且史蒂夫·伯吉斯给我们发了这么多来自这一集的精彩幕后照片，简直就像是一座照片宝藏。他确实发了。我们也会把这些放到动态里。
Well, let's get started. Here we are. We're at Shroot Farms. The wedding guests are arriving and they're bringing cats as gifts. I loved it. Here's how this scene was described in the shooting draft. Kevin puts his cat in the gift basket. Behind him, Pete has a cat for her too.
好吧，我们开始吧。我们到了。我们在施鲁特农场。婚礼宾客陆续到达，并把猫作为礼物带过来。我太喜欢了。拍摄初稿中是这样描述这个场景的：凯文把他的猫放进礼品篮里。他身后，皮特也为她准备了一只猫。
Behind him, Creed wearing his beard puts a cat in the basket. Behind him, Pete has a cat for her too. Behind him, Creed, wearing his beard, puts a cat in the basket. The cats keep escaping from the basket. A caterer keeps scooping them up and putting them back in the basket. Meredith shows up with a cat. She looks gorgeous and classy. Oh. Mmm. Well, that's a little bit more than what we see play out in the scene. In this scene, we do see Dakota introduce herself to Creed.
他身后，戴着胡子的克里德把一只猫放进篮子里。猫不断从篮子里逃跑。一个餐饮服务人员不断把它们抓起来放回篮子里。梅雷迪思带着一只猫出现了。她看起来华丽而高雅。哦。嗯。嗯，这比我们在场景中实际看到的要多一点。在这个场景中，我们确实看到达科塔向克里德作了自我介绍。
This is when we learn her name. Creed says he's Jeff Bumato. He sells ceramic tile out of Newark. Yeah, he has a wife named Catherine. He can show you his social security card if it helps. Dakota's like, okay, whatever. I would like to point out that our writers, Jen Salata and Graham Wagner, are reprising their roles as the Schrut family members. They're arriving for the wedding during the scene as well.
这就是我们得知她名字的时候。克里德说他是杰夫·布马托。他在纽瓦克卖瓷砖。是的，他有一个叫凯瑟琳的妻子。如果需要的话，他可以向你展示他的社保卡。达科塔的反应是，好吧，随便吧。我要指出的是，我们的编剧詹·索拉塔和格雷姆·瓦格纳正在重新扮演施鲁特家族成员的角色。他们也在这个场景中为婚礼到达。
– Now we see Kelly and Ravi, they're in their seats for Dwight and Angela's wedding. When Ryan approaches, he's got a baby strapped to his chest. – I have a show and tell moment for here. – Oh, already? – Already. – What is it? – Kelly and Ravi are holding the wedding program. Oh! And I kept one. Phil Shea gave it to me and I still have it. Look, Sam, Cassie, I
– 现在我们看到凯莉和拉维，他们坐在德怀特和安吉拉婚礼的座位上。当瑞恩走近时，他胸前绑着一个婴儿。 – 我这里有一个展示和讲述的时刻。 – 哦，已经开始了吗？ – 已经开始了。 – 是什么？ – 凯莉和拉维拿着婚礼节目单。 – 哦！ – 我留了一张。菲尔·谢伊给我的，我到现在还留着。看，萨姆，卡西，我
have the wedding program. Wow, that is a good prop to have. We share this in our book as well, but it says that Angela and Dwight's wedding is taking place on Saturday, the 14th of June at three o'clock in the afternoon. Okay. It says that her co-maids of honor are Pam Halpert, Meredith Palmer, Phyllis Vance, and Rachel Martin. So that was actually a plot point that got cut out. It's why we are all throwing your bachelorette party because we are your co-maids of honor. And the groomsmen are Andy Bernard, Oscar Martinez, Zeke Schrute, and Mo Schrute. Bestest Minch, Jim Halpert. Angela does not have a maid of honor. Oh, interesting. It also lists Dwight and Angela's parents. Do you want
有婚礼节目单。哇，那是一个很好的道具。我们在书中也分享了这个，但上面写着安吉拉和德怀特的婚礼将于6月14日星期六下午三点举行。好的。上面写着她的伴娘是帕姆·哈尔珀特、梅雷迪思·帕尔默、菲利斯·万斯和蕾切尔·马丁。所以那其实是一个被剪掉的情节。这就是为什么我们都为你举办单身派对，因为我们是你的伴娘。伴郎是安迪·伯纳德、奥斯卡·马丁内斯、齐克·施鲁特和莫·施鲁特。最佳男士，吉姆·哈尔珀特。安吉拉没有首席伴娘。哦，有趣。上面还列出了德怀特和安吉拉的父母。你想
to hear their names? Sure. We're gonna see Angela's parents later. Angela's mother and father are Anne-Marie Martin and Sean T. Martin. Okay.. Angela's mother and father are Anne Marie Martin and Sean T. Martin. Dwight's mother and father are Hedda Mannheim Schrute and Dwight Schrute Sr. There was a flower girl, Cece Halpert. And the ring bearer was Philip Halstead Lipton. There you go, Dwight and Angela's wedding program. Well, that was all done by the late, great Phil Shea. Yep. Kelly's gonna ask Ryan if he's a manny. And Ryan's like, no, this little guy's mine.
听听他们的名字吗？当然。我们稍后会看到安吉拉的父母。安吉拉的母亲和父亲是安妮-玛丽·马丁和肖恩·T·马丁。好的。安吉拉的母亲和父亲是安妮·玛丽·马丁和肖恩·T·马丁。德怀特的母亲和父亲是赫达·曼海姆·施鲁特和老德怀特·施鲁特。还有一个花童，茜茜·哈尔珀特。戒指童是菲利普·哈尔斯特德·利普顿。给你，德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼节目单。好吧，这一切都是由已故伟大的菲尔·谢伊完成的。是的。凯莉要问瑞恩他是不是男保姆。瑞恩说，不，这个小家伙是我的。
Mm-hmm. I would like to give the cutest smile in the finale, Dundee, in this scene. Is it to the little baby? Yes, what a cutie. Steve Birch has said we had three pairs of twins. Oh wow. As possible babies, but there was one baby
嗯哼。我想把大结局中最可爱微笑奖颁给这个场景中的某个人。是给那个小宝宝吗？是的，真是个小可爱。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们有三对双胞胎。哦，哇。作为可能的婴儿候选，但只有一个婴儿
and he unfortunately did not know the name that was like superior to all the babies and that's the one you see there, winning the smiley Dundee. What a cutie. Oh, I wanna give a guest star shout out to Centil Rama Murthy who played Ravi. He's back.
而他不幸不知道那个名字，那个凌驾于所有婴儿之上的婴儿，也就是你在那里看到的那个，赢得了微笑邓迪奖。真是个小可爱。哦，我要向扮演拉维的森蒂尔·拉玛穆蒂表达客串明星的谢意。他回来了。
He's amazing. He's so good. He's so good. Well, Kelly thinks Ryan's baby is adorable, especially compared to some of the Uggos that Ravi treats as a pediatrician. Ravi says they're called premature, sweetie. It's good to see you again, Ryan. And you know, from the minute Ryan sits down,
他太棒了。他太厉害了。他太厉害了。嗯，凯莉觉得瑞恩的宝宝非常可爱，尤其是跟拉维作为儿科医生治疗的一些丑八怪相比。拉维说，亲爱的，那叫早产儿。很高兴再次见到你，瑞恩。你知道的，从瑞恩坐下的那一刻起，
we see a look on Kelly's face, and I think we all know what's gonna happen. Oh, you know it. You know it. We are now in the bridal dressing room. Pam, Phyllis, and Angela's sister, Rachel, are helping Angela get ready. Angela's really struggling in her heels.
我们看到凯莉脸上的表情，我想我们都知道会发生什么。哦，你懂的。你懂的。我们现在来到新娘化妆室。帕姆、菲利斯和安吉拉的姐姐蕾切尔正在帮安吉拉准备。安吉拉穿着高跟鞋非常吃力。
I guess, you know, spending hours in a trunk, her legs are all sore. She can't really stand up or walk. And she's really mad at Phyllis about it. This is the first time we see Angela in her wedding dress. Yes, that's true. We've mentioned this before, but it looks very similar to Phyllis's wedding dress. It's a strapless dress with a lace jacket.
我想，你知道的，在后备箱里待了几个小时后，她的腿都酸了。她真的无法站立或行走。为此她真的很生菲利斯的气的。这是我们第一次看到安吉拉穿着婚纱。是的，确实如此。我们之前提到过，这看起来非常类似于菲利斯的婚纱。这是一件无肩带连衣裙，配有一件蕾丝外套。
Angela's hair is half up, half down. This was a very fun wardrobe fitting. I still have the pictures from it. And of course, Kim Ferry wanted to do a little classic mini bun swoop. So her hair is half up, half down with the cute little knot. I saw it. I loved it. It was a great detail and a call back to the character.
安吉拉的发型是半扎半放。这是一次非常有趣的服装试穿。我至今还保留着那时的照片。当然，金·费瑞想要做一个经典的小迷你发髻挑逗。所以她的头发是半扎半放的，带着一个可爱的小结。我看到了。我很喜欢。这是一个伟大的细节，也是对角色的致敬。
Well, Phyllis is going to tell Angela, I'm going to get you to the altar and you can take that to the bank. Yes. I have such a clear memory of Phyllis saying you can take that to the bank. She was so proud that she was going to take care of things and it was a really sweet moment. Well now we're going to go to the groom's dressing room. Dwight's getting ready. Jim is helping him. We have a callback, another little Easter egg. Dwight does his air guitar to pump himself up.
嗯，菲利斯要对安吉拉说，我要把你送到圣坛前，你可以把这话当真。是的。我对菲利斯说“你可以把这话当真”有着非常清晰的记忆。她为自己能把事情处理好而感到骄傲，那是一个非常甜蜜的时刻。现在我们要去新郎的化妆室了。德怀特正在准备。吉姆在帮他。我们有一个致敬，另一个小彩蛋。德怀特弹起空气吉他来给自己打气。
Oh, yes! I love that. He's like, I was born ready. And it's that callback to what he would do in the stairwell before there was a big meeting. Well, Jim's going to give him some news. He says, I just found out that I cannot be your bestest mensch because the bestest mensch has to be older than the groom. What are we gonna do? Rain and John are really funny in this scene.
哦，是的！我喜欢那个。他说，我生来就准备好了。这是对他在有重要会议之前在楼梯间会做的事情的致敬。嗯，吉姆要告诉他一些消息。他说，我刚发现我不能当你的最佳男士，因为最佳男士必须比新郎年长。我们该怎么办？雷恩和约翰在这个场景里非常搞笑。
They are. When John is Jim is like, I'm significantly younger than you and Dwight's like, I don't know if I'd say that. Significantly. Maybe a teeny bit. That's when Jim says, I just really wish there was something I could do. And then his eyes kind of look off.
确实如此。当约翰扮演的吉姆说，我明显比你年轻时，德怀特说，我不知道我是否会这么说。明显。也许微乎其微。那就是吉姆说，我真的很希望我能做点什么。然后他的眼神有点飘忽不定。
The camera pans over, and guess who's there? Michael Scott. I know. And Dwight says, Michael, I can't believe you came. And Michael says, that's what she said. And that's the last time Steve Carell ever said that's what she said. And that's the last time Steve Carell ever said that's what she said. He has not said it since. That was the last time. Well, it was perfect. That's going to be your last one. That's a great way to go.
摄像机摇过去，猜猜谁在那儿？迈克尔·斯科特。我知道。德怀特说，迈克尔，真不敢相信你来了。迈克尔说，她也这么说。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔最后一次说“她也这么说”。这也是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔最后一次说“她也这么说”。他再也没说过。那是最后一次。好吧，这太完美了。这将是你的最后一句。这真是一个完美的退场方式。
Perfect. Jim says, best prank ever. Now it's time for the wedding ceremony. The processional begins and Phyllis is carrying Angela on her back while a string quartet plays Sweet Child of Mine. Steve Burgess said Sweet Child of Mine was very difficult to clear. This is the song the writers wanted. But since we did not use Guns N' Roses singing it, it was allowed, but it still cost $50,000. Damn! Just to have a string quartet play it. Popular song. It was allowed, but it still cost $50,000. Damn.
太棒了。吉姆说，史上最棒的恶作剧。现在是婚礼仪式的时候了。送亲队伍开始入场，菲利斯背着安吉拉，同时弦乐四重奏演奏着《Sweet Child of Mine》。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，《Sweet Child of Mine》版权非常难买。这是编剧们想要的歌。但既然我们没有用枪炮与玫瑰乐队的原唱，这就获批了，但它仍然花了五万美元。天哪！仅仅是为了让弦乐四重奏演奏它。热门歌曲。这获批了，但它仍然花了五万美元。天哪。
Just to have a string quartet play it. Popular song. Wow. I have to think that Angela and Dwight had a few arguments over the song choices for the wedding. You think so? I don't think Angela would have picked Sweet Child of Mine as her entrance. We got a fan question from Jenna F. in Los Angeles who said, this seemingly simple bit of Phyllis carrying you down the aisle actually required a pretty elaborate set of circumstances to pull off.
仅仅是为了让弦乐四重奏演奏它。热门歌曲。哇。我猜安吉拉和德怀特在婚礼的选曲上肯定有过一些争吵。你觉得呢？我不觉得安吉拉会选《Sweet Child of Mine》作为她的入场曲。我们收到了来自洛杉矶的粉丝珍娜·F. 的提问，她说，这个看似简单的由菲利斯背着你走过过场的桥段，实际上需要一套相当复杂的环境条件才能实现。
You wrote about it in your book, The Office BFFs, but Angela, will you tell the story on the podcast? Thank you, Jenna F. for writing in. You've been a loyal writer, commentator on this podcast. Well, this is how it was described in the shooting draft. Dwight stands in a shallow grave with an empty one next to him. Beside Jim and Andy and the ushers under a bower of flowers. The guests are in suits and look great, seated on hay bales with white cloths covering the
你在你的书《办公室好闺蜜》里写过这件事，但是安吉拉，你能在播客里讲讲这个故事吗？谢谢珍娜·F. 的来信。你一直是这个播客的忠实读者和评论员。好吧，这就是拍摄剧本中的描述方式。德怀特站在一个浅坑里，旁边还有一个空坑。紧挨着吉姆、安迪和迎宾员，站在花拱门下。客人们穿着西装，看起来棒极了，他们坐在干草垛上，上面盖着白色的布。
tops. Phyllis walks down the aisle with Angela riding on her back, smiling and nodding to all the guests. When she gets to the front, Angela daintily steps off and into the grave next to Dwight. But to make this walk down the aisle happen, well, first of all, Phyllis could not carry me down the aisle. That was not safe for her to do.
菲利斯走过过道，安吉拉骑在她的背上，微笑着向所有客人点头。当她走到前面时，安吉拉优雅地从背上下来，走进了德怀特旁边的坑里。但是为了让这场走红毯的戏得以实现，首先，菲利斯不可能背着我走过过道。她这么做并不安全。
So they actually got a stunt woman that had Phyllis's similar hair color that carried me down the aisle. And we had to practice this. I had a rehearsal. So we had to set up two different angles for the camera. The camera that would be behind Phyllis and I walking down the aisle were really filming me on the back of
所以他们实际上找了一个发色和菲利斯相似的特技演员来背我走过过道。我们不得不为此进行练习。我进行了一次排练。所以我们必须为摄像机设置两个不同的角度。拍摄我和菲利斯走过过道的背后的摄像机，实际上是在拍我骑在……
the stunt woman because you couldn't see her face. And I am really being carried and that's why you see my legs dangling, right? But of course they also needed a shot of us coming towards the camera and as we walked towards the camera it was actually Phyllis and me behind her on this wooden plank being held by two men. Yes. And we had to practice the walk together because Phyllis does one step together, you know, that traditional kind of walk down the aisle where you take one step and then your feet come together and you take one step.
特技演员背上的画面，因为你看不到她的脸。我是真的被背着，这就是为什么你能看到我的腿在晃荡，对吧？但当然，他们也需要我们走向摄像机的镜头，当我们走向摄像机时，实际上是菲利斯和我，在我身后的一块由两个男人抬着的木板上。是的。我们必须一起练习这种走法，因为菲利斯是一步一并地走，你知道，那种传统的走红毯方式，你迈出一步，然后双脚并拢，再迈出一步。
So we had to practice this and there was one time where Phyllis got too far ahead and my arms are on her neck and the men with the plank did not meet her and I almost fell off the thing. It was such a crazy thing to see, Angela, because we're all sitting there being the wedding guests and, you know, the two guys holding you on a piece of wood and you're sort of holding onto Phyllis. And then they removed the guys in post. And the wood. Which is so crazy to me,
所以我们必须练习这个，有一次菲利斯走得太快了，我的胳膊搭在她的脖子上，抬木板的男人没有跟上她，我差点从那个东西上面掉下来。看到那一幕真是太疯狂了，安吉拉，因为我们都坐在那里扮演婚礼宾客，你知道，两个家伙用一块木头把你抬着，你有点抓着菲利斯。然后他们在后期制作中把那两个家伙移除了。还有那块木头。这对我来说太疯狂了，
because I remember I turned to John and I was like, I don't understand. We can just paint them out? We can just get rid of them? Yeah. He was like, uh-huh, they did. There's a whole wooden plank and tube in. You wouldn't expect that on The Office,
因为我记得我转向约翰，我说，我不明白。我们可以直接把他们P掉吗？我们可以直接除掉他们吗？是的。他说，嗯哼，他们做到了。整块木板和管道都在。你不会在一档像《办公室》这样的节目里期待这个，
there would be like an elaborate special effects moment. But this was, this was of the caliber of something you might see in The Matrix, dare I say. Exactly. Oh, thank you for bringing The Matrix into the finale. I needed Keanu to be here with us in some way for the finale. I really appreciate that.
会有一种精心制作的特效时刻。但这，这达到了你在《黑客帝国》中可能会看到的水平，我敢说。没错。哦，谢谢你把《黑客帝国》带到大结局里。我需要基努以某种方式和我们一起出现在大结局中。我真的很感激。
There are so many things that have happened to us over the last five years since we have been making this podcast. I was going over them in my head. I was thinking of life and just world events and all kinds of things. And I was filled with such gratitude for all the things that we've done, you know, over
在我们制作这个播客的过去五年里，发生了太多事情。我一直在脑海中回顾它们。我在思考生活、世界各地的重大事件以及各种各样的事情。对于我们在过去五年里所做的一切，我充满了感激之情。
these five years. But I thought, I am not done here, though. I am not done. And the one thing, the one thing that we have not managed to capture in this five years is Keanu. I know. And so we cannot stop podcasting. Until.
这些年。但我想，我还没结束呢。我还没结束。而有一件事，我们在五年里唯一没有成功捕捉到的东西就是基努。我知道。所以我们不能停止做播客。直到。
Until we have that. Until we get to interview Keanu. You know, he's gonna be on Broadway and waiting for Godot with Alex Winter. And that's next fall. And I feel like that's a reason to come talk to us. Maybe we go to the play and then we talk to them in New York City. Well lady, you know any reason to go to New York City
直到我们拥有那个。直到我们采访到基努。你知道，他要和亚历克斯·温特一起在百老汇出演《等待戈多》。那是今年秋天。我觉得这是一个来跟我们谈谈的理由。也许我们去看话剧，然后在纽约市和他们谈谈。好吧，女士，你知道去纽约市的任何理由。
and see a play I'm all over it. Done! Done. I do want to say while we've been talking our balloons that say congrats have fallen. They're hanging on by one string. We have a few other things to cover from this scene. Number one, I want to say I think Greg Daniels should have won an Emmy for this episode in particular for all these wedding scenes. They are so funny. So funny. And so well done.
去看一场话剧，我绝对奉陪。说定了！说定了。我确实想说，在我们说话的时候，写着“祝贺”的气球已经掉了。它们只剩下一根绳子挂着了。我们还有其他一些关于这个场景的事情要讨论。第一，我想说，我认为格雷格·丹尼尔斯本该凭这一集赢得艾美奖，特别是为了所有这些婚礼场景。它们太搞笑了。太搞笑了。而且做得太好了。
I love that even though Angela Martin is on Phyllis's back, she is still waving to people who are seated. Kind of awkwardly, my hand is in Phyllis's face. I'm holding a bouquet in the other hand while I'm trying to hold on. I love that Kevin fist bumps Angela and she fist bumps him back. And Meredith gives her real enthusiastic thumbs up. Those were improv moments. And it's just such a happy thing.
我喜欢尽管安吉拉·马丁趴在菲利斯背上，她仍然在向坐着的 人挥手。姿势有点尴尬，我的手挡在了菲利斯的脸上。我另一只手拿着一束花，同时还要努力抓住。我喜欢凯文和安吉拉碰拳，她也回敬了他一个拳。梅雷迪思竖起了热烈的大拇指。这些都是即兴发挥的时刻。这真是一件快乐的事。
And then when Angela crawls into her, Michael comes over and gives her a hug that was not in the script. Steve did that in the moment. And I love it. I'm just so happy to see him. I'm hugging him for real. 31 minutes, 6 seconds. I want to give a shout out to the couple who I assume are playing Angela's parents.
然后当安吉拉爬向他时，迈克尔走过来给她一个拥抱，这不在剧本里。史蒂夫当时即兴发挥了那一幕。我好喜欢。我看到他太高兴了。我是真的在拥抱他。31分6秒。我想向扮演安吉拉父母的那对夫妇致敬。
They're in the front row, both tiny folks, both blonde, and then when Oscar comes down the aisle with Philip, the woman playing Angela's mother is just gazing at Philip like a grandma would. Also wanna give a shout out to Michael Tuba-Heathernton. He is back, he is the minister, and he's gonna marry Dwight and Angela. Yes, that's Veda's husband. Veda, our script supervisor, and he was the minister in the farm,
他们坐在第一排，两个都是小个子，都是金发，然后当奥斯卡带着菲利普走过过道时，扮演安吉拉母亲的那个女人正凝视着菲利普，就像祖母那样。还要向迈克尔·图巴-希瑟顿致敬。他回来了，他是牧师，他将为德怀特和安吉拉主持婚礼。是的，那是维达的丈夫。维达，我们的剧本主管，他是农场里的牧师，
but he's had multiple roles on the show. Yes, we've broken down. He has been so many different characters. He's sort of like our soap star who keeps coming back as different characters. He is or like Kirk from Gilmore Girls. You know, Sean Gunn played the character of Kirk on Gilmore Girls, but he has like multiple jobs and like even for a while had multiple names. Oh, very much like Kirk then. Yes. Well, now we're gonna have Kevin read a passage.
但他在剧中扮演过多个角色。是的，我们盘点过。他扮演过很多不同的角色。他有点像我们的肥皂剧明星，不断以不同的角色回归。他确实是，或者就像《吉尔莫女孩》里的柯克。你知道，肖恩·古恩在《吉尔莫女孩》中扮演了柯克这个角色，但他有很多工作，甚至有一段时间有多个名字。哦，那确实很像柯克。是的。好吧，现在我们要让凯文朗诵一段。
Yes, it's from the Song of Solomon. We had a fan question. Okay. From Stephanie C. in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. What is this timeline for wedding guests? First of all, Dwight and Kevin just buried the hatchet yesterday and now he's not only at the wedding, but he's a reader?
是的，选自《雅歌》。我们有一个粉丝提问。好的。来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的斯蒂芬妮·C。婚礼宾客的时间线是怎样的？首先，德怀特和凯文昨天才刚刚言归于好，现在他不仅参加婚礼，还是朗诵者？
And Angela had Kevin read at her wedding? Then Erin just met her parents this morning and now they're at the wedding of her coworkers? Not only are these people extremely flexible with their day, but Angela and Dwight are extremely flexible with their wedding plans. I'm sorry, but as head of the PPC, I'm surprised she would allow for these last-minute changes. I don't disagree. All right. We also have a bullsh**t card from Annette G in Newcastle, Australia, who said,
安吉拉居然让凯文在她的婚礼上朗诵？然后艾琳今天早上才刚见到她的父母，现在他们就来参加她同事的婚礼了？这些人不仅对自己的日程安排极其灵活，安吉拉和德怀特的婚礼计划也极其灵活。不好意思，但作为PPC（派对策划委员会）的主席，我惊讶于她竟然会允许这些最后一分钟的改变。我并不否认。好吧。我们还收到了一张来自澳大利亚纽卡斯尔的安妮特·G的胡扯卡，她说，
I call bullsh**t. They took time to introduce Dwight's siblings on the farm only for them to disappear from the show and not even attend the wedding? In the farm, and I know it was created with the intention of being a pilot, but it was still an episode in the office. They showed this bond between Dwight and his siblings and nephew
我大喊胡扯。他们花时间在农场里介绍了德怀特的兄弟姐妹，结果他们却从节目中消失了，甚至没有出席婚礼？在《农场》那一集里，我知道它的创作初衷是作为一个试播集，但它仍然是《办公室》的一集。他们展示了德怀特和他的兄弟姐妹以及侄子之间的这种纽带，
only for none of them to be at his wedding. I so agree with this. Where is his brother? Where is his sister? And his cute little nephew who he taught how to milk? Yes. I see that bullsh** card and I raise it. What do you raise it to? Super bull****** card and I raise it. What do you raise it to?
结果他们中没有一个人去参加他的婚礼。我太赞同这一点了。他的兄弟在哪里？他的妹妹在哪里？还有他教过怎么挤奶的可爱小侄子呢？是的。我收下那张胡扯卡并加码。你加码到什么？超级胡扯卡，我加码到这个。你加码到什么？
Super bull******. Okay. Good. Well, people had more things to say. Cora C. in East Hampton, Massachusetts said, this bothers me every time I watch this episode. Why have none of the children aged? Both Cece and Philip look the same as a year ago. Cora, it's true, and we actually discussed this, but here's the thing. Those kids were such cute petudes, and we were so attached to them, we just put them in the episode anyway.
超级胡扯。好吧。很好。好吧，大家还有更多话要说。马萨诸塞州东汉普顿的科拉·C说，每次我看这一集，这都困扰着我。为什么所有的孩子都没有长高？西西和菲利普看起来都和一年前一模一样。科拉，这是真的，我们实际上讨论过这件事，但事情是这样的。那些孩子太可爱了，我们对他们产生了很深的感情，我们还是把他们放进这一集里了。
It's true. Philip should be a year older. Cece should be older. I know. We don't care. I hear it, I get it, but also I always find it jarring when one of your shows all of a sudden the character's aged and they look so different. Like they're clearly not the same person. Right, exactly. We would have to cast a whole new person.
确实如此。菲利普应该大了一岁。西西应该更大了。我知道。我们不在乎。我听到了，我懂，但我也总是觉得，当你的某个节目里角色突然长大了，而且看起来很不 一样时，会让人感到格格不入。就像他们明显不是同一个人。对，没错。我们得重新选一个全新的人。
Yeah. And I think you might've been like, who's Oscar carrying down the aisle? We had to know it was Philip. Yeah. And I think you might've been like, who's Oscar carrying down the aisle? We had to know it was Philip. Yeah. You know, and Jim looking at the unveiling last episode, he needed to have the Cece that we all know. Yeah.
对。而且你可能会想，奥斯卡抱着走过过道的是谁？我们必须知道那是菲利普。是的。而且你可能会想，奥斯卡抱着走过过道的是谁？我们必须知道那是菲利普。是的。你知道，吉姆看着上一集的揭幕仪式，他需要我们都熟悉的那个西西。是的。
So. I know, I know. Ah. All right. I have something I noted. Okay. I spotted Val sitting next to Nate. You know, in the last episode we were talking about the people who were on the panel versus off the panel,
所以。我知道，我知道。啊。好吧。我记下了一点。好的。我发现瓦尔坐在内特旁边。你知道，在上一集中，我们一直在谈论参加座谈会的人与没有参加座谈会的人，
and I thought about listing Val because she was not on the panel, but I kind of thought, you know what, I bet she moved on. Maybe she moved on. We don't even know. Does she still work in the warehouse? I'm not sure. But here she is, she's at the wedding, but she's not sitting with Daryl, but later on she's gonna leave with Daryl. What's happening? Do you think they were broken up?
我曾考虑把瓦尔列进去，因为她没有参加座谈会，但我想了想，你知道吗，我打赌她已经向前看了。也许她已经向前看了。我们甚至都不知道。她还在仓库工作吗？我不确定。但她在这儿，她参加了婚礼，但她没有和达里尔坐在一起，不过后来她会和达里尔一起离开。这怎么回事？你觉得他们分手了吗？
Are they gonna hook up after this wedding? Is it one of those where they're like, he's been gone? Yeah, it might be a wedding hookup. They happen. I had a wedding hookup at my wedding. I had a wedding. I know you. I know who it was too. It was not me. Had sex in the bushes of my wedding. That is crazy. My real life wedding to Lee. Yeah. Two of the people I had already left in the bushes. I had already left. Or did they just make out? I think it was like heavy petting make out.
他们会在这个婚礼之后勾搭上吗？这算不算那种情况，他们就像是，他已经走了？是的，这可能是婚礼上的勾搭。这种事会发生。我自己的婚礼上就发生过婚礼勾搭。我有过一场婚礼。我认识你。我也知道那是谁。那不是我。在我的婚礼灌木丛里做爱。太疯狂了。我和李的现实生活中的婚礼。是的。我留在那里的两个人已经在灌木丛里了。我已经走了。还是他们只是在亲热？我觉得就像是那种很激烈的热吻。
This is what I heard. Do people still say heavy petting? Is that a term? I don't know. I've never spoken to them about it. I've never spoken to either of them about it. Guys, they're famous. Two famous people did some heavy petting
这是我听说的。现在人们还说“激烈热吻”吗？这是一个词吗？我不知道。我从没跟他们谈过这件事。我从没跟他们俩任何一个人谈过这件事。伙计们，他们是名人。两个名人在我的婚礼灌木丛里做了一些激烈的热吻。
in the bushes of my wedding. There's an Office Lady 6.0. I was surprised. I was like, okay. I was surprised. You know, I wasn't, I wasn't. Because here's the thing, it was your wedding, so you're busy. People are coming around you.
这里有个《办公室好闺蜜》6.0版本。我很惊讶。当时我想，好吧。我很惊讶。你知道，我没有，我没有。因为事情是这样的，那是你的婚礼，所以你很忙。人们围在你身边。
You got a lot going on. I observed this from the beginning. I was like, what? What? What? What? What's happening over there? You saw sparks flying. I saw some looks happening, like Kelly and Ryan kind of looks. Yeah. Yeah. And I was like, what? What? What? What? What?
你有很多事要忙。我从一开始就观察到了这一点。当时我想，什么？什么？什么？什么？那边在发生什么？你看到火花四溅了。我看到了一些眉目传情，就像凯莉和瑞恩那种眼神。对。对。然后我想，什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? Okay, where are we? Okay, I know one thing I want to talk about, which is now the minister pronounces them man and wife and he says, release the doves. Yeah. The doves do not move. They do not.
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？好吧，我们到哪儿了？好吧，我知道我想谈的一件事，就是现在牧师宣布他们结为夫妻，他说，放飞鸽子。是的。鸽子一动不动。它们根本不动。
Everyone has this huge reaction like, what? Like the reaction does not match what's happening, in my opinion. Like, so the doves don't fly away. People wouldn't be like, what? I don't know. Does it feel like bad luck that the doves don't fly? That was how I interpreted it, that everybody was like, oh no, the doves aren't flying for their love. For their love.
每个人的反应都极其夸张，像是在说，什么？在我看来，这种反应和正在发生的事情完全不匹配。所以鸽子没有飞走。大家不至于表现得像“什么？”吧。我不知道。鸽子不飞，这感觉像是不吉利吗？我是这么解读的，每个人都在想，哦不，鸽子没有为他们的爱情飞翔。为了他们的爱情。
So funny how you said that. Well, I'll tell you, there was a reason. Okay. So I remember this gag for the wedding. I remember talking about it with Phil. The idea was that one of the things Angela had on her registry were cats. You could bring her cats.
你这么说太搞笑了。好吧，我告诉你，这背后是有原因的。好吧。所以我记得婚礼上的这个恶作剧。我记得和菲尔讨论过这件事。本来的想法是，安吉拉婚礼登记单上的其中一项是猫。你可以给她带猫。
They have this basket of cats. Well, it said in the shooting draft, after the minister says release the doves, Nate bends to the wicker cage that has a dozen cats clawing at it. He shoes the cats away and opens a door. Doves shoot out in a hurry to get the hell out of there. Everyone applauds. I have this very clear memory of talking to Phil Shea about it and asking him, how is this going to work? You can't really have cats clawing at the basket, you know? And I guess they were going to do some movie magic with that.
他们有一个装满猫的篮子。好吧，拍摄剧本上写着，在牧师说放飞鸽子之后，内特弯腰走向那个藤条笼子，里面有十几只猫在里面抓挠。他把猫赶走，打开了一门。鸽子急忙飞奔出来，想要赶紧离开那个鬼地方。大家鼓掌。我有一个非常清晰的记忆，就是和菲尔·谢伊谈论这件事，问他，这要怎么运作？你总不能真的让猫在篮子里抓挠吧，你知道的？我猜他们会用电影特效来处理这个。
And ultimately, it didn't work. And I asked Steve Burgess about it, and he said when they went to release the doves, the doves would not fly. Oh, that just happened. That was real. That was real. He said maybe it was the wind or the stormy weather, but they wanted to stay in their little basket. They were happy. They did not want to leave it. So then they had the character of Nate
最终，这行不通。我问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯关于这件事的细节，他说当他们去放飞鸽子时，鸽子根本不肯飞。哦，那竟然是现场发生的。那是真的。那是真的。他说也许是因为风或者暴风雨天气，但它们就是想呆在它们的小篮子里。它们很开心。它们一点也不想离开。所以他们只好让内特这个角色去赶它们出来。他说它们就是不肯飞走。在最后的剪辑里，他们确实放飞了一两只，但它们只是在篮子周围来回走动。所以他们不得不通过电脑特效做出这些鸽子在篮子周围走动而不是飞翔的画面。他们必须用特效把它们弄掉。哇。是的。所以我们不得不移除两个抬木板的男人和几只懒惰的鸽子。几只懒惰的鸽子。每个人都有那种反应，是因为我们被告知篮子里有猫在抓挠。哦，我们当时还在推进那个剧情。是的。明白了。
trying to shoo them out. And he said they would not fly away. And in the final cut, they did get one or two out, but they just walked back and forth around the basket. So they did have to CGI these doves walking around the basket and not flying. They had to CGI them out. Wow. Yeah. So we had to remove two men in a plank and some lazy doves. Some lazy doves. And everyone had the reactions they had because we were told there are cats clawing at the basket. Oh, we were still doing that story. Yes. Got it.
所以这就是为什么每个人都有那么大的反应，因为感觉猫可能会杀死这些鸽子。对。但这些都没有发生。他们把大家的反应保留了下来。好吧，我现在的最爱时刻之一马上要来了。这是一个小小的时刻，但德怀特和安吉拉交换了戒指，他们接吻了，他们结婚了。
So that's why everyone has that huge reaction, because it's like cats are maybe going to kill these doves. Right. But none of that happened. They left the reactions in. Well, one of my favorite moments now is coming up. It's a small moment, but Dwight and Angela, they exchange their rings and they kiss and they're married.
德怀特说，各位，你们坐的干草垛也就是你们在招待会上的座位。所以这里有一些干草钩。随通道放置了免费的干草钩。直接把它扎进去就行了。你的那个时刻是关于小埃德·贝格利的吗？是的，是的。哦天哪，直接把它扎进去就行了。你的那个时刻是关于小埃德·贝格利的吗？是的，是的。哦天哪，太棒了。只是，我能为他颁发一个邓迪奖，表彰他试图移动干草垛时摔的那一跤吗？他的投入度太高了，太惊艳了。他摔倒了，干草垛直接压在他身上。太棒了。我最喜欢的一点是，还记得艾琳踢箱子然后她的腿卡在里面吗。她的脚卡住了，鞋子也掉了出来。他们的。太棒了。我最喜欢的一点是，还记得艾琳踢箱子然后她的腿卡在里面吗。她的脚卡住了，鞋子也掉了出来。这感觉就像是这个家族基因里自带的。我真的很喜欢。是的，我也是。我确实有一张胡扯卡要在这里打出来。
And Dwight says, everyone, the hay you're sitting on are also your seats for the reception. So there's some hay hooks. Complementary hay hooks are placed on the aisle. Just stab them on in there. Is your moment about Ed Begley Jr.? It is. It is. Oh, gosh stab him on in there. Is your moment about Ed Begley Jr. It is, it is. Oh gosh, it's so good. Just, can I give him a Dundee for best pratfall
是什么？不是超级胡扯。只是胡扯。就普通的？我们在招待会上再也没看到过干草垛。我们再也没看到过它们。我们再也没看到过它们。那是椅子。我知道。我知道。好吧，女士，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，我们就去那个完全没有干草垛的招待会。不过那里有一场相当精彩的第一支舞。确实有。我们回来了，德怀特和安吉拉正在跳他们的第一支舞。跳的是克鲁 Motley Crue 的《Angela》，德怀特正抱着安吉拉转圈。这呼应了你的腿还在疼的那个梗。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的粉丝萨拉·M. 的提问，她说，安吉拉在婚礼舞蹈中用了威亚吗？
for his fall when he's trying to move the hay bale. It's so committed and so amazing. He falls and the hay bale comes on top of him. It's so good. What I loved about it is remember when Erin kicks the box and then her leg gets stuck in it. Her foot gets stuck and she loses her shoe. of them. It's so good. What I loved about it is remember when Erin kicks the box and then her leg gets stuck in it. Her foot gets stuck and she loses her shoe. It felt like it is in this family's DNA. I just really loved it. Yeah, I did too. I do have a bull
不，萨拉说，安吉拉在婚礼舞蹈中用了威亚吗？没有，萨拉，我没有用威亚。那是雷恩抱着我。他全程都抱着我。拍摄剧本中的描述是这样的：德怀特和安吉拉伴随着汤姆·佩蒂的歌曲《Here Comes My Girl》跳他们的第一支慢舞。哦，对，这首歌确实在后面出现了。
s**t card to play here. What is it? It's not super bull s**t. It's just bull s**t. Just regular? We never see the bales of hay at the reception. We never see them again. We never see them again. It's chairs. I know. I know. Well, lady, why don't we take a break and when we come back we'll go to the reception with no hay bales added at all. But there is a pretty awesome first dance. There is. We are back and Dwight and Angela are having their first dance. It is to Motley Crue's Angela and Dwight is carrying Angela around. This is a callback to the fact that your legs are still hurting you. We had a fan question from Sarah M. in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania who said, was Angela in a harness
剧本上说，我们展现了德怀特把安吉拉举得离他的脸更近，她的脚在空中晃荡。嗯哼。剧本里就写了这么多。雷恩和我即兴创作了我们的整个第一支舞。我喜欢他们把歌换成了克鲁 Motley Crue 的《Angela》。我觉得这太契合当时的天气了，我想让我们听听看。当风在呼唤安吉拉时，那是一个有风有雨的暴风雨天，就是这首歌。
for the wedding dance? No, Sarah said, was Angela in a harness for the wedding dance? No, Sarah, I was not in a harness. That was just Rain holding me. He held me the whole time. It was described in the shooting draft like this. Dwight and Angela are dancing their first slow dance to the Tom Petty song, Here Comes My Girl. Oh, yeah, which that song does come later.
但是，当我们开始跳舞时，雷恩做了一个非常棒的探戈动作。然后当他转身时，我的腿顺势踢了出去，我故意让双腿保持僵硬，这样它们就会在身后飞扬起来。我们玩得太开心了。你看到的所有的笑容都是真的。我们当时玩得太开心了。好吧，看他们跳舞真是一种享受。
The script says, we reveal that Dwight is holding Angela up closer to his face, her feet dangle. Mm-hmm. That's all it said. Rain and I improvised our whole first dance. I loved that they changed it to Montlie Cruz Angela. I think it fit the weather so perfectly, I want us to hear it. When the winds cry Angela, it was a windy stormy day and this was the song.
充满了欢乐。感觉就像是一场真正的招待会。确实如此。真的非常像。然后德怀特说。感觉就像是一场真正的招待会。确实如此。真的非常像。然后德怀特说，大家一起来加入我们吧。然后你就听到了汤姆·佩蒂的《Here Comes My Girl》。吉姆和帕姆有了这样一个非常甜蜜的时刻。是的。哦，等等，卡西，你有什么要说的吗？对，我在这个场景的背景里发现了一点东西，皮特和艾琳正在一起跳舞。所以我觉得他们这个时候还在约会。哦，好眼力。
But yeah, when we started dancing, Rain did this really great tango move. And then when he turned, my legs kind of kicked out and I purposely held them rigid so they would fly out behind me. We had such a blast. All of the smiles you see are real. We were having so much fun. Well, it was fun to watch.
我没有注意到。我也没有。我后来在这一集里注意到，他们和艾琳的父母坐在一起，但在婚礼期间他们并没有坐在一起。我们又有了一场婚礼勾搭吗？有没有可能他们当时没在一起？因为他们在座谈会上就没有坐在一起。
It was very joyous. It felt like a real reception. It did. It really did. And then Dwight says. It felt like a real reception. It did. It really did. And then Dwight says, everybody else come join us. And that's when you hear Tom Petty's Here Comes My Girl. And Jim and Pam have this really sweet moment. Yes. Oh, wait, Cassie, what you have something? Yeah, I have something I noticed in the background of the scene, Pete and Aaron are dancing together. So I think they're still dating at this point. Oh, good catch.
在婚礼举行的时候他们没有在一起，但是现在这里他们没有在一起，因为他们在座谈会上并没有坐在一起。在婚礼举行的时候他们没有在一起，但现在他们在这里一起跳舞，然后他坐在她的桌子旁。我的意思是，婚礼上就是会发生这种事。很明显。人们会勾搭上。好眼力，卡西。说到勾搭，瑞安正要走向拉维。
I did not catch that. I didn't either. I caught that later in the episode, they are seated together with Erin's parents, but they were not seated together during the wedding. Do we have another wedding hookup? Is it possible that they were not together? Because they were not together on the panel.
他需要一些关于小德雷克的帮助。他给小德雷克吃了一颗草莓，明知他过敏，明知他会出现皮疹和发烧，好把拉维支开，这样他就能去和凯莉勾搭了。这对凯莉来说是最浪漫的举动。她简直不敢相信，然后他们当场就亲热起来了。没错，她说，你为了跟我说话，竟然给你的孩子吃引起过敏的东西。
They're not together as the wedding is happening. But now here they were not together, because they were not together on the panel. They're not together as the wedding is happening, but now here they are dancing together, and then he sits at her table. I mean, this is what happens at weddings. Clearly. People hook up. Good catch, Cassie. And speaking of hookups, Ryan is about to approach Ravi.
她非常感动。她现在春心萌动了。她确实是。现在我们来到这个温馨的场景，迈克尔正在向帕姆展示他孩子的照片。太可爱了。我很喜欢能和史蒂夫有这个时刻。我把他完全据为己有。
He needs some help with baby Drake. He gave baby Drake a strawberry, knowing he's allergic, knowing he would have this rash and fever to get Ravi away so he could hook up with Kelly. It's the most romantic gesture to Kelly. She can't believe it, and they start making out right there. Yep, she says, you gave your baby an allergic reaction just to talk to me.
我知道。在我们拍摄这一小段的20分钟左右里。帕姆说，迈克尔有太多的照片，他不得不弄了两部手机，有两个号码和两笔账单，但他只是太高兴能拥有一个家庭套餐了。太甜蜜了，简直甜得要命。我们收到了关于这个小片断的大量粉丝来信。来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的萨默·J说，
She's very moved. She's hot to trot now. She sure is. Now we have this sweet scene where Michael is showing photos of his kids to Pam. So cute. I loved getting to have this moment with Steve. I got him all to myself.
我很难相信迈克尔不会带霍莉去参加婚礼。这是不是与艾米·瑞安因档期冲突而无法出席有关？看到剧集末尾有这么多客串演员出现，但迈克尔一生的挚爱却不在，这看起来真的很奇怪，也有点悲伤。请解释一下。萨默，这确实是档期冲突。原本的设定是让霍莉也来参加婚礼，并带上他们的孩子。但艾米·瑞安在这些日期没有档期。
I know. For about 20 minutes while we shot this little bit. Pam says, Michael has so many photos, he had to get two phones with two numbers and two bills, but he's just so happy to have a family plan. So sweet, so stinking sweet. We had a fan mail flurry about this little moment. Summer J from Houston, Texas said,
剧本里本来为霍莉安排了一段单人访谈，她本该抱着他们的孩子，也就是一对爱尔兰双胞胎（指出生时间相近的两胎）。来自加拿大多伦多的伊丽莎白·P说，我们发现迈克尔和霍莉有好几个孩子。这是否意味着他去做了第三次输精管切除术的复通手术？剪断，啪，剪断，啪，剪断，啪。还有来自科罗拉多州奥罗拉的伊凡娜·O的粉丝提问，她说，我非常想知道迈克尔给他的孩子起名叫什么。
I find it hard to believe that Michael would not bring Holly to the wedding. Was this a scheduling conflict with Amy Ryan who could not attend? It just seems so strange and a little sad that we see so many cameos at the end of the show, but the love of Michael's life is gone. Please explain. Summer, it was a scheduling conflict. It was originally intended for Holly to also come to the wedding and also bring their kids. But Amy Ryan was not available on these dates.
剧本大纲或删减片段里有告诉我们这个吗？有的。霍莉的单人访谈。没错，读出来吧，珍娜。上面写着，当德怀特和迈克尔在背景里伴随着《罗莎莉塔》一起跳舞时，霍莉本来会有这样一段单人访谈。
There was a talking head that was scripted for Holly and she was gonna be holding their children, some Irish twins. Elizabeth P from Toronto, Canada said, we find out that Michael has a few kids with Holly. Does this mean he got his third vasectomy reversed? Snip, snap, snip, snap, snip, snap. And also a fan question from Ivana O in Aurora, Colorado, who said, I'm dying to know what Michael named his kids.
所以我们看到了这一幕的发生，但这本该是这段单人访谈出现的地方，霍莉是这么说的，生活真美好。我们有两个儿子，切本希尔和洛沙宾。是迈克尔起的名字。他说这是根据他第一次看到他们时的感觉决定的。然后我们本会看到孩子们在跳舞。
Is there anything in the show Bible or deleted scenes that tell us this? There is. Holly's talking head. That's right, read it, Jenna. It says, Holly was gonna have this talking head while Dwight and Michael were dancing together in the background to Rosalita.
切本希尔？切本希尔和洛沙宾。切本希尔怎么拼？C-H-E-B-O-N-S-H-U-R。切本希尔。还有洛沙宾。L-O-W-S-H-E-B-I-N。好吧，当他们去迪士尼乐园时，别人都能找到印着自己名字的冰箱贴，
So we see this happen, but that's where this talking head would have been and Holly says this, life is good. We have two sons, Chebenshire and Loshaben. Michael named them. He said it was based on the feeling he had when he first saw them. Then we were gonna see the kids dancing.
他们可找不到。他们找不到的。但你知道，只有迈克尔一个人来参加婚礼，这对我来说挺合理的。我的意思是，当你有年幼的孩子时，如果你没有育儿嫂，你们中就会有一个人留在家。你得把这些活动分工一下，决定谁能去参加什么，有没有人能照看孩子？如果不能，你们中一个人去，另一个人留在家里。你得把这些活动分工一下，决定谁能去参加什么，有没有人能照看孩子，
Chebenshire? Chebenshire and Loshabin. How do you spell Chebenshire? C-H-E-B-O-N-S-H-U-R. Chebenshire. And Loshabin. L-O-W-S-H-E-B-I-N. Well, when they go to Disneyland and everyone else can find a magnet with their name on it,
如果实在不行，你们中一个人去，另一个人不参加。是的。所以这对我来说说得通。对我也说得通。好吧，现在我们看到了一段人们在跳舞的蒙太奇。首先登场的是艾琳和她的父亲，他们跳得一模一样。太甜蜜了。
they're not going to be able to. They will not. But you know, it made sense to me that just Michael came to the wedding. I mean, when you have young kids, if you don't have childcare, one of you stays home. You kind of have to divide up these events and say who can go to what, can someone watch the kids? And if they can't, one of you goes and one of you stays home. You kind of have to divide up these events and say who can go to what, can someone watch the kids
太甜蜜了。现在托比和帕姆一起跳舞，托比全程都在痛哭流涕。是的，他非常伤心。帕姆说，是因为我吗？是因为内莉吗？他回答说，是因为这一切。托比。
and if they can't, one of you goes and one of you doesn't. Yeah. So that made sense to me. It made sense to me too. Well now we have a montage of people dancing. First up are Erin and her father and they dance just the same. So sweet.
你知道吗？我很高兴我们把这个拍进去了，因为这在婚礼上也经常发生。这就是我要说的。总会有那么一个人爱哭鼻子。没错。现在菲利斯和斯坦利一起跳舞。这太可爱了。菲利斯说，我想你了。斯坦利说，我也想你了。
So sweet. Now Toby and Pam dance together and Toby just sobs the whole time. Yes, he's very sad. Pam's like, is it me? Is it Nellie? And he's like, it's everything. Toby.
然后菲利斯有了一段最甜美的单人访谈。她在这里流下了真实的眼泪，因为我们所有人都开始变得相当难过。随着我们拍摄大结局的日子一天天过去，我们要对这部剧说再见了，这种感觉变得越来越真实。是的。菲利斯有一段单人访谈，她说，
You know what? I'm glad we had that because that also happens at weddings. That's what I was gonna say. There's always some person who is just weepy. Yep. Now Phyllis and Stanley dance together. This is so cute. Phyllis says, I missed you. Stanley says, I missed you too.
人们以为斯坦利是个刻薄的老顽固，但一个刻薄的老顽固会做这个雕像送给她吗？那是一个菲利斯雕像，因为他告诉过我们他会雕刻鸟类。是的。现在他把菲利斯雕成了一只鸟。是的，上半部分是菲利斯，然后她的腿就像鸟的腿。太可爱了。关于这段单人访谈我有一个秘密。
And then Phyllis has the sweetest talking head. She's crying real tears here, because we were all getting pretty sad. With each passing day as we filmed the finale, it got just more and more real that we were saying goodbye to the show. Yeah. Phyllis has a talking head where she says,
什么秘密？菲利斯其实不在婚礼现场。她在邓德米夫林的停车场里，用的是绿幕背景。哦。因为我们在大天空牧场拍摄时，那个雕刻还没做好。所以他们必须后来再去取。你根本看不出来那是绿幕。
people think that Stanley is a mean old grump, but would a mean old grump make this statue of her? And it's like Phyllis, because he told us he carves birds. Yeah. Now he's carved Phyllis as a bird. Yeah, the top half is Phyllis, and then her legs are like bird legs. It's so cute. I have a secret about this talking head.
这做得太好了。这是来自史蒂夫·伯吉斯的内部机密消息。这真的是电影特效。我们确实收到了大量粉丝的来信，想知道菲利斯有没有把那只鸟留作纪念，她确实留了。她在接受我们的采访时说过她留下了这个。我跟她发短信确认过，因为我觉得我们之前不知道她把它放在哪里。她说她把它放在她的家庭办公室里。因为我觉得我们之前不知道她把它放在哪里。她说她把它放在她的家庭办公室里。所以她虽然没有她那个毛茸茸的海狸邓迪奖，但她有那个鸟类雕刻。
What is it? Phyllis is not at the wedding. She's in the Dunder Mifflin parking lot with a green screen. Oh. Because the carving wasn't ready when we were up at Big Sky Ranch. So they had to pick it up later. You cannot tell that's a green screen.
好吧，我很高兴她拥有它。我也是。凯利和瑞安现在要一起离开婚礼现场了。他们正沿着山坡跑向汽车。瑞安说，我爱你。凯利说，我也爱你。瑞安说，我们要永远在一起。凯利说，我们要奔向夕阳。
That's really well done. That's some secret intel from Steve Burg screen. That's really well done. That's some secret intel from Steve Burgess. That's some movie magic. We did get a fan mail flurry of people wanting to know if Phyllis got to keep the bird and she did. She said that in her interview with us that she kept this. I texted with her because I don't think we knew where she keeps it. She said she keeps it in her home office. because I don't think we knew where she keeps it. She said she keeps it in her home office. So she does not have her bushiest beaver dundee, but she does have the bird carving.
然后瑞安说了这句台词，我的天啊。他说，我终于掌握了对感情的承诺。在抛弃了自己的亲生孩子之后，他说他掌握了对感情的承诺。我很喜欢这对情侣的结局。太完美了。这完全符合他们的性格。太完美了。
Well, I'm glad she has it. Me too. Kelly and Ryan are now gonna leave the wedding together. They're running down the hill to their cars. Ryan says, I love you. Kelly says, I love you too. Ryan says, we're gonna be together forever. And Kelly says, we're running off into the sunset.
好吧，招待会现在正处于高潮。德怀特和迈克尔正在一起跳舞。看到这两个家伙在舞池里玩得这么开心，我真的很喜欢。安吉拉和她的姐姐蕾切尔也在跳舞。我们的舞步是即兴发挥的，我们决定跳得一模一样。同样在跳舞的还有梅雷迪思和一个男人。是的。
And then Ryan has this line, OMG. He says, I finally mastered commitment. As he leaves his own child behind, he's mastered commitment. I liked the sending for this pairing. It's perfect. It was all in character. It's so perfect.
那个男人是凯特·弗兰纳里的现实生活中的男朋友，也是我们的剧组合影摄影师，克里斯·哈斯顿。后来在仓库里，他也将是为我们拍照的摄影师。所以我喜欢想象他其实是派去参加德怀特和安吉拉婚礼并记录这一切的公共电视台摄影师。我们还有另一场婚礼勾搭。但这也呼应了她现实生活中的浪漫恋情，
Well, the reception is now in full swing. Dwight and Michael are dancing together. I loved seeing these two guys having fun on the dance floor. Angela and her sister Rachel are dancing as well. We improvised what our dance moves would be, and we decided we'd dance just the same. Also dancing are Meredith and a man. Yes.
因为他就是我们的摄影师。没错。我们收到了来自新泽西州费尔劳恩的斯蒂芬·K的粉丝提问，他说：“‘所有人都在伴随着斯普林斯林的《罗莎莉塔》跳舞。’‘这首歌是怎么决定的？’‘买下这首歌花了多少钱？’”好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，
That man was Kate Flannery's real-life boyfriend and our set photographer, Chris Haston. Now later in the warehouse, he's also going to be the photographer who's taking our photo. So I like to imagine that he was the PBS photographer sent to Dwight and Angela's wedding to document things. And we have another wedding hookup. But it mirrors her real life romance
“我们一直想用这首歌。它写在剧本里了。这首歌的建议就在剧本里。而布鲁斯·斯普林斯林的歌曲非常难买到版权，甚至几乎不可能买到。所以史蒂夫当时想，好吧，我会尽最大努力试一试。他说这花了一段时间。我们发现我们的请求直接送到了布鲁斯本人手里。
because he was our photographer. That's right. We got a fan question from Stephen Kay in Fairlawn, New Jersey who said, "'Everybody's dancing' to Springsteen's Rosalita. "'How was this song decided on "'and how much did it cost to get the song?' Well, Steve Burgess said,
哇。他是《办公室》的粉丝，并说，你们可以用这首歌。这花了很多钱。老板同意了。老板同意了。花了他多少钱？10万美元。所以我希望你们所有人都能享受那个舞蹈场景。
"'We always wanted to use it. "'It was scripted. "'This was in the script, this song suggestion. And Bruce Springsteen songs are very difficult, if not impossible to clear. So Steve was like, I mean, I'll give it my best shot. He said it took a while. We found out that our request went to Bruce himself.
哇哦。好吧，拉维现在带着小德雷克回来了，然后他从凯文那里得知凯利和瑞安已经离开了。他把孩子交给凯文，说给儿童福利局打电话，他们会找到比瑞安更好的人来照顾他。拉维是个儿科医生，对吧，他就要把孩子交给凯文，然后说给儿童福利局打电话，内莉要从凯文手里把孩子接过来。她太开心了。
Whoa. He was a fan of The Office and said, you can use the song. It cost a lot of money. The boss agreed. The boss agreed. What did it cost? $100,000. So I hope you all enjoy that dance scene.
她终于有自己的孩子了。我们收到了一张来自纽约州奥尔巴尼的凯尔·M的胡扯卡，他说，你不能就这样抱走一个孩子，内莉，尤其是在摄像机前，尤其是在飞往欧洲的飞机上。尤其是带出国外。你就是不能这么做。我觉得这是一张超级胡扯卡。
Wowza. Well, Ravi is now going to return with baby Drake, and then he learns from Kevin that Kelly and Ryan have left. And he gives the baby to Kevin says call child services they'll find someone better to take care of him than Ryan. Ravi is a pediatrician yeah and he's just gonna hand the baby to Kevin yeah and say call child services yeah Nellie is gonna take the baby from Kevin. She's so happy.
确实是。凯尔说，编剧们在处理其他角色的结局时都处理得很好，也合乎情理，但这次我必须大喊胡扯。这是一张带脏话的胡扯卡。好吧，现在我们听到了这句著名的迈克尔·斯科特的台词。他看着帕姆、吉姆、安吉拉和德怀特。他们在交谈，在欢笑。
She's finally going to have her baby. We had a bullsh-t card from Kyle M in Albany, New York who said, you can't just take a baby, Nellie, especially on camera, especially on an airplane, to Europe. Especially out of the country. You just can't. I think that's a super bullsh** card.
你知道，我觉得我们真的需要听听这句话。我觉得我的孩子们都长大了，然后他们彼此结婚了。这是每个父母的梦想。每个父母的梦想。是的。安吉拉，我们收到了大量的粉丝来信。哦，是的。
It is. Kyle said, the writers wrap things up so well with the other characters in believable ways, but now I call bullsh**. It's a F-bomb bullsh**. Well, now we have this famous Michael Scott line. He is watching Pam and Jim and Angela and Dwight. They're talking, they're laughing.
全是全大写字母。安吉拉，别忘了那个绦虫的故事。你答应过我们要讲的。你答应过要告诉大家我们在迈克尔的单人访谈背景里到底在聊什么。我们在笑什么？好吧。
And you know, I just think we need to hear it. I feel like all my kids grew up and then they married each other. It's every parent's dream. Every parent's dream. Yeah. Angela, we had a fan mail flurry. Oh yeah.
我们在我们的书《办公室好闺蜜》里分享了一点这方面的内容，但我会把整个故事讲给你听。当摄像机在迈克尔做单人访谈时从他身边推过去时，你看到了安吉拉、德怀特、帕姆和吉姆，我们都在笑。而且我表现得非常生动，比安吉拉·马丁平时的样子生动多了。我显然在讲一个故事。你知道，肯·夸普斯告诉我们，我们在后面说什么并不重要，观众是听不到的。所以我们就真的开始闲聊了。我不知道这个话题是怎么挑起的，
In all caps. Angela, don't forget the tapeworm story. You promised us you would tell us. You promised that you would tell everybody what we were talking about back there in the background of Michael's talking head. What are we laughing about? All right.
但雷恩给我们讲了一个故事，说他小时候在尼加拉瓜长大的时候得过绦虫。他在他的书里写过这件事。他写过，就是《巴松管之王》。他说他当时正走在路上，屁股发痒。我是在引用雷恩的话。雷恩是这么说的，他的屁股发痒，他伸手去挠想看看怎么回事，结果从屁股里拽出了一条虫子。我是在引用雷恩的话。雷恩是这么说的，他的屁股发痒，他伸手去挠想看看怎么回事，结果从屁股里拽出了一条虫子。
Well, we shared a little bit about this in our book, The Office BFFs, but I will tell you the whole story. When the camera pushes past Michael while he's doing this talking head, you see Angela, Dwight, Pam and Jim, and we are all laughing. And I am being very animated, way more animated than Angela Martin ever would. I'm clearly telling a story. And you know, Ken Quapus told us, it doesn't matter what we're saying back there, we're not going to hear you. So we just really started chatting. And I don't know how this subject came up,
是的。嗯哼。我们当时都惊呆了，什么？这分享得也太随机了。这分享得也太随机了。我们都开始大笑，但我笑得喘不过气来，一直在笑，然后你问我，女士，怎么了？我说，我姐姐得过绦虫。然后我们所有人都开始大笑。我的意思是，她现在没事了，伙计们。但当我们住在印度尼西亚时，她确实得了这种绦虫。
but Rain told us the story of how he had a tapeworm when he was a kid growing up in Nicaragua. He wrote about it in his book. He did, the Bassoon King. He said he was walking down a road and his butt itched. I'm quoting Rain. Rain said this, his butt itched and he reached up to see what was going on and he pulled a worm out of his butt itched. I'm quoting Rain. Rain said this, his butt itched and he reached up to see what was going on and he pulled a worm out of his butt.
然后我把这个故事讲给了你们所有听。这就是背景里正在发生的事情。我说，事情是这样的。它在她的体内潜伏了好几年。然后有一天它醒了。约翰简直听不下去了。约翰简直听不下去了。他当时说，你在说什么鬼话？它潜伏着。然后她开始出现一些胃部问题。就像，她好像怎么都吃不饱，你知道的，因为那条绦虫在抢她的食物。是的。是的。然后她去看医生。他们尝试了……
Yeah. Mm-hmm. We were like, what? It was such a random share. It was such a random share. We all started laughing, but then I couldn't catch my breath and I was laughing and laughing and you're like, lady, what's going on? And I said, my sister had a tapeworm. And then we all started laughing. I mean, she's fine now, you guys. But when we lived in Indonesia, she got this tapeworm.
对。嗯。我们当时就想，什么？这分享得太随性了。这分享得太随性了。我们都开始大笑，然后我就喘不过气来，一直在笑，一直在笑，然后你就像在说，女士，怎么了？我说，我妹妹有条绦虫。然后我们都开始大笑。我是说，她现在没事了，各位。但是当我们住在印度尼西亚时，她得了这条绦虫。
And I told all of you this story. This is what's happening in the background. I said, here's the deal. It laid dormant in her body for years. And then one day it woke up. John couldn't take it. John could not take it. He was like, what are you talking about? It laid dormant. And then she started having like some stomach issues. Like, it's like she couldn't eat enough, you know, because the tapeworm was like eating her food. Yeah. Yeah. Then she went to doctors. They tried,
我把这个故事讲给你们所有听。这就是背景发生的事情。我说，是这样的。它在她体内潜伏了多年。然后有一天它醒了。约翰简直受不了。约翰简直无法接受。他当时就想，你在说什么？它潜伏着。然后她开始出现一些胃部问题。就像，她好像怎么吃都吃不饱，你知道的，因为绦虫在吃她的食物。对。对。然后她去看医生。他们尝试了，
you know, what's going on. They couldn't figure out what was going on. Then everything stopped. It went dormant again for years. And then it woke up. She had this like yo-yo thing happening in her body for so long. And then finally a doctor figured it out that she had this tapeworm and they gave her this medicine. This also wrecked John. He was like, what did they do? I said, they gave her this medicine that killed the worm inside her and then she pooped it out. That's what we were talking about.
你知道，到底发生了什么。他们弄不清楚发生了什么。然后一切都停了下来。它沉寂了好几年。接着它又苏醒了。她的身体里就像有个摇摇板一样折腾了那么久。最后终于有个医生查出来她有绦虫，然后给她开了药。这事也把约翰整崩溃了。他当时问，他们做了什么？我说，他们给她开了药，把她体内的虫子杀死了，然后她把虫子拉出来了。这就是我们当时在聊的事。
There it is. Those are some tapeworm stories and we were cracking up. It was probably one of those you had to be there's, but we were so thrown by rain share and then we thought we were done and then I was like, wait a second, I got one about a table worm that went dormant for years. That was a nice moment. I remember. We were laughing so hard. Well, the wedding is over now. Val, Daryl, Meredith, Andy and Pete are all leaving. They convinced Toby to join them in the warehouse
就是这样。这就是一些关于绦虫的故事，当时我们笑得前仰后合。这可能属于那种“当时不在场就体会不到”的笑话，但我们当时被雷·谢尔（rain share）彻底整懵了，然后我们以为聊完了，接着我说，等一下，我还有一个关于一条沉寂了好几年的绦虫的故事。那是段美好的时光。我记得。我们笑得太厉害了。好了，婚礼结束了。瓦尔、达里尔、梅雷迪思、安迪和皮特都要走了。他们说服托比和他们一起去仓库
for a documentary after party. Yeah. Andy says it's only six. Come on, let's go. Six p.m. I'm glad I have the wedding program that said the wedding started at three because I feel like 6 p.m. is a quick wedding and also 6 p.m. and it's done? That's so early. Listen, I have some things to say about this. This is the longest day.
参加纪录片的会后派对。对啊。安迪说只有六点。拜托，我们走吧。下午六点。我很庆幸我拿着婚礼流程单，上面写着婚礼三点开始，因为我觉得下午六点是一场很快的婚礼，而且下午六点就结束了？这也太早了吧。听着，关于这个我有些话要说。这是最漫长的一天。
This day started with a panel discussion. Then we all went home and changed clothes. We went to a wedding, a reception. Yeah. Everyone's leaving the wedding reception. It's still light out and we still have another documentary reception to attend. It's a big day.
这一天是以小组讨论开始的。然后我们都回家换了衣服。我们去参加了一场婚礼，还有招待会。对啊。大家都离开了婚礼招待会。天还亮着，我们还要去参加另一个纪录片的招待会。这是盛大的一天。
This is a big day. Before we leave the wedding all together though, I really need to give an award to the best outfit at the wedding. Who is it? Val. Oh, she looks so chic. Her dress is gorgeous.
这是盛大的一天。不过在我们彻底离开婚礼之前，我真的得给婚礼上最佳着装颁个奖。是谁？瓦尔。哦，她看起来太时髦了。她的裙子美极了。
It's very structured. The top of it is like a tank top neckline. It's white. Then there's a big square of this vibrant blue with a high waist with like two gold kind of belt buckle accessories on the waistband. And then the bottom is black. She's got this gorgeous blue wrap, a gold braided bracelet, and a green handbag with
它非常有立体感。裙子上半部分就像背心的领口。是白色的。然后是一个巨大的高腰亮蓝色方块，腰带上还带着两个金色的腰带扣配饰。然后下半部分是黑色的。她披着一条华丽的蓝色披肩，戴着金色编织手镯，还有一个带有
white trim. She looks fantastic. You really liked this outfit. I loved this outfit. That's quite a description. Well, it was really a showstopper, and I think she gets best outfit at the wedding. Something that I failed to mention until now
白色饰边的绿色手提包。她看起来棒极了。你真的很喜欢这套衣服。我太喜欢这套衣服了。这描述可真够详细的。嗯，它真的是惊艳全场，我觉得她当之无愧是婚礼最佳着装。直到现在我才忘了提的一件事
is Pam's disappearing flower. Oh, flower in the hair? Yeah, flower in the hair, flower not in the hair. In the hair, not in the hair. You know what happened? When? We put a flower in my hair hair and we shot for a whole day and then we were like, I don't know if we like this flower.
就是帕姆消失的花。哦，头发上的花？对，头发上的花，后来头上又没花了。在头上，没在头上。你知道发生了什么吗？什么时候？我们在我头发上插了一朵花，拍了一整天，然后我们觉得，不知道我们是不是喜欢这朵花。
So we just took it out. Oh no. I was like so, so there you go. When Jim and Pam arrive home, Pam does not have a flower in her hair and they are tired. Pam's like, oh, this day. I mean, yeah, because you still have to go change clothes and go to another event.
所以我们就把它拿掉了。哦，不。我当时就……所以，就这样。当吉姆和帕姆回到家时，帕姆的头上没有花，而且他们很累。帕姆就说，哦，这日子。我是说，对啊，因为你还得去换衣服，去参加另一个活动。
But guess who walks out of their house? Nancy Carell. Nancy Carell. Because Pam has sold their house. I have so many bullsh** cards to play here. Well, yes. There's this really fun scene where Jim's like, what's happening?
但你猜谁从他们家里走出来了？南希·卡瑞尔。南希·卡瑞尔。因为帕姆把他们的房子卖了。我在这里简直有无数张胡扯牌可以打。好吧，是的。有个非常有趣的场景，吉姆问，怎么回事？
Who are these people? Carol walks out of their house with a couple of potential home buyers. And this is when Pam says, I just wanted to say thank you for being so great this past year. And I don't want you to have to give up anything to be with me.
这些人是谁？卡瑞尔和几个潜在的购房者一起从他们家里走了出来。这就是帕姆说的时候，我只想说谢谢你过去这一年这么棒。我不想让你为了跟我在一起而放弃任何东西。
So to show you how much I love you and to show you how much I believe in your future, I have been showing our house for about two months. Two months! Yeah. He's like, oh, that's why it's so clean. She's like, uh-huh. Uh-huh.
所以为了向你展示我有多爱你，为了向你展示我多么坚信你的未来，我已经把我们的房子带人参观看了大约两个月。两个月！对啊。他当时想，哦，怪不得这么干净。她就说，嗯哼。嗯哼。
And then she has this line, you know, you bought it without telling me. I thought maybe I could sell it without telling you. Kaboom! This is such a great marriage. This is, okay, thank you for saying that. I know that this is supposed to be a big romantic gesture. It feels a little tit for tat, but I know for the story they want Pam and Jim to be able to move on together, you know? Yes, Jim got his big moment with the teapot. They wanted Pam to have a big moment,
然后她有这样一句台词，你知道，你买它的时候没告诉我。我想也许我可以不告诉你把它卖了。轰！这婚姻太棒了。这，好吧，谢谢你这么说。我知道这本该是一个重大的浪漫姿态。感觉有点一报还一报，但我知道剧情需要帕姆和吉姆能够一起继续前行，你知道吗？是的，吉姆用茶壶迎来了他的高光时刻，他们希望帕姆能有一个高光时刻，
moment with the teapot. They wanted Pam to have a big moment. But I said in the writer's room, I said, I'm not sure that the answer to this couple's problems is for Pam to adopt this habit of making big life moves without consulting the other person. Yeah, they don't want to be the gotcha couple. Gotcha, sold the house. I know.
带着茶壶的高光时刻。他们希望帕姆能有一个高光时刻。但我在编剧室里说过，我说，我不太确定这对夫妻问题的答案，是让帕姆养成未经商量就做出重大生活决定的习惯。对，他们不想成为那种“捉弄人”的夫妻。捉弄你，把房子卖了。我知道。
It's like, here's what we're doing now. Actually, originally, they were going to come home and there was going to be a sold sign in the yard. And Jim was going to be like, what's this? So I said, maybe their big romantic gesture is that she's been showing the house. But you notice in the scene, they do actually decide together to do the move. The people say, we'll take it. And then Pam kind of looks at Jim. So in a way, Pam is like offering an opportunity. And then they do finally agree on something together in the moment. And I was like, Okay, I like that. That does feel romantic. Yeah. And they hug. They're super happy. I did love that both Steve and Nancy got to be in the finale. I thought that was really nice. Yes. And the home buyer was played by Jay Falk, our season nine script coordinator.
这就好比，这就是我们现在的计划。其实原本，他们回家时院子里会竖起一个“已售”的牌子。吉姆会问，这是什么？所以我说，也许他们伟大的浪漫姿态是她一直在带人看房。但你在场景中会注意到，他们实际上是在那一刻共同决定搬家的。买房的人说，我们要了。然后帕姆看了看吉姆。所以某种程度上，帕姆就像是在提供一个机会。然后他们最终在那一刻就某事达成了一致。当时我想，好的，我喜欢这样。这确实感觉很浪漫。对。然后他们拥抱了。他们超级开心。我确实很高兴史蒂夫和南希都能出现在大结局中。我觉得这真的很棒。是的。购房者由杰伊·福克饰演，他是我们第九季的剧本协调员。
Well, Pam and Jim are now going to arrive at the PBS viewing party. It was described in the shooting draft like this. Interior warehouse. We see people from the office mixing with various members of the crew. There is a promotional backdrop with the logo for the office and American workplace on it. Kevin and Meredith pose with several executives for a picture. After the picture is taken, they try to walk away, but another group approaches them and they have to pose for another picture. There's a table with food and refreshments and another table is full of office and American workplace swag.
好吧，帕姆和吉姆现在要到达PBS的观看了。拍摄初稿里是这样描述的。内景仓库。我们看到办公室的人们与剧组的各种成员打成一片。背景板上印有办公室和美式职场（The Office and American Workplace）的标志。凯文和梅雷迪思与几位高管一起摆姿势拍照。照片拍完后，他们试图走开，但另一群人向他们走过来，他们不得不为另一张照片摆姿势。有一张桌子摆满了食物和茶点，另一张桌子则摆满了办公室和美式职场（American Workplace）的周边纪念品。
Phyllis and Stanley are examining the swag. Phyllis takes a mug and a production person stops her and says, these are for PBS executives only. Well, the person who says that is Alison Jones. That's right. She said Greg really wanted her to be in a scene and she was kind of reluctant, but she said, I'll do it if my scene is with Phyllis.
菲利斯和斯坦利正在检查周边。菲利斯拿了一个马克杯，一个制片人员拦住她并说，这些仅供PBS高管使用。嗯，说这句话的人是艾莉森·琼斯。没错。她说格里格真的很想让她出现在一个场景中，她有点勉强，但她说，如果我的场景是和菲利斯一起，我就演。
Aw. Because they were coworkers, you know? Yeah. There is now a montage of scenes of everyone mixing and mingling and talking. Yeah. Pam is going to unveil her big mural, her warehouse mural called The History of Us. She dedicates it to Jim and the crowd applauds and Pam says, oh, let's take a photo in front
噢。因为他们曾经是同事，你知道吗？对。现在是一段蒙太奇剪辑，展示了每个人都在交际、寒暄和交谈。对。帕姆将揭幕她的巨幅壁画，她的仓库壁画，名为“我们的历史”。她把它献给吉姆，人群欢呼鼓掌，帕姆说，哦，我们在它前面拍张照吧
of it. And all these people crowd in for the photo. This was another opportunity for Greg to get some of our crew members in there. And Greg. And Greg. Greg is who has his arm around Pam. I thought this was really moving to watch because you see so many faces from our show,
所有这些人蜂拥而上拍照。这又是格里格让我们的剧组人员出镜的一个机会。还有格里格。还有格里格。格里格就是那个搂着帕姆胳膊的人。我觉得看这个真的让人很感触，因为你看到了我们剧中的那么多面孔，
so many of our amazing crew, our writers, our producers, our editors, the directors, the cast, and you get to hear Kate Flannery's real-life boyfriend, Chris Hasten's voice, as he's taking the pictures. Yes, I noticed Howard Klein, Stephanie, RAD, who I recently texted about my party, Rusty Mahmood, Veda, Dave Rogers is in there, Claire Scanlon is in there, there's so many people.
看到了我们那么多优秀的剧组人员、我们的编剧、我们的制片人、我们的剪辑师、导演、演员，你还能听到凯特·弗兰纳里的现实生活男友克里斯·黑斯廷斯在拍照时的声音。对，我注意到了霍华德·克莱恩、斯蒂芬妮·拉德（我最近还给她发短信聊我的党派），拉斯蒂·马哈茂德、维达，戴夫·罗杰斯也在里面，克莱尔·斯坎伦也在里面，有太多人了。
It's like... It's our show. It's our is in there, there's so many people. It's like, it's our show. It's our show. Yeah, it's our show family. We had a question from Mary M. from Maryland who said, who painted Pam's mural? Well, Mary, it was painted by Jules Comesco. She's the person who did all of our office art. But here's the thing. It was not finished when we had to shoot this scene. It was still in the conception phase, like Greg was still making tweaks to what this mural would be. So we are actually posing and reacting in front of a blank wall. Steve Burgess said that they were working on this mural until the very last minute, until 2 a.m. the night before the episode aired. Oh my goodness.
这就像……这是我们的节目。这是我们的在里面，有太多人了。这就像，这是我们的节目。这是我们的节目。对，这是我们的节目大家庭。我们收到了来自马里兰州的玛丽·M.的一个问题，她说，是谁画了帕姆的壁画？嗯，玛丽，它是由朱尔斯·科梅斯科画的。她就是负责我们所有办公室艺术的人。但问题是。当我们拍摄这个场景时，它还没完成。它还在构思阶段，比如格里格还在对这幅壁画的最终模样进行微调。所以我们实际上是在一面空白墙前摆姿势和做出反应。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，他们一直在画这幅壁画，直到最后一分钟，也就是剧集播出前一晚的凌晨两点。噢天哪。
She never painted it on the wall. She painted a smaller version, which they then superimposed onto the wall in post, and that smaller version he thinks Greg got to keep. Oh, that's really cool. Yeah. Well, in this montage of the PBS party, we also do see Dave Rogers and Terry Weinberg, they even have a little scene together, and it's in deleted scenes. Well, now you see the employees giving each other
她从来没有把它画在墙上。她画了一个较小的版本，然后他们在后期制作中将其叠加到了墙上，他认为格里格把那个小版本留作纪念了。哦，那太酷了。对。好吧，在PBS派对的这段蒙太奇中，我们确实也看到了戴夫·罗杰斯和特里·温伯格，他们甚至还有一个简短的对手戏，而且是在被删减片段里。好吧，现在你看到员工们互相交换着
little sly glances and sort of motioning toward the staircase that goes nowhere. And that's because they have plans to have their own little Dunder Mifflin party up in the bullpen. Yep. And when they get up there, the phone rings just as Jim and Pam are entering. Jim goes and sits at his desk and Pam notices the phone is ringing. And she answers it. She says, Dunder Mifflin, this is Pam.
狡黠的眼神，并且有点示意朝向那个通往死胡同的楼梯。那是因为他们计划在办公区楼上办他们自己的小型邓德米夫林派对。没错。当他们走到楼上时，正当吉姆和帕姆进来，电话就响了。吉姆走过去坐在他的办公桌前，帕姆注意到电话在响。她接起了电话。她说，邓德米夫林，我是帕姆。
I really wanted to say that line one more time because I improvised that in one of our early morning work sessions on the pilot. And I remember Greg saying, oh, that's so good. That's so realistic. And I said, well, that's how I used to answer the phone at all my jobs. I would say the company, This Is Jenna. And he goes, I love that. That's a great detail.
我真的很想再把这句台词说一次，因为这是我在试播集的一次清晨工作会议上即兴发挥的。我记得格里格说，哦，太棒了。太真实了。我说，嗯，我以前在所有工作岗位上都是这样接电话的。我会说公司名称，我是珍娜。他说，我喜欢这个。这是个很棒的细节。
And that then became part of my character. Yeah. So that was one of the things I said to Greg. I had very interesting requests for the finale. I was like, I want a scene with all the ladies. And I want one more chance of saying, Dunder Mifflin, this is Pam. Because I haven't been the receptionist for a long time.
然后这就成了我角色的一部分。对。所以这是我对格里格提出的要求之一。我对大结局有着非常有趣的要求。我说，我想要一个所有女士都在场的场景。我还想要最后一次机会说，“邓德米夫林，我是帕姆”。因为我已经很久不是前台了。
And I wanted to sit behind that desk just one more time before the show was over. Well, I loved it. I mean, Jim clocks it. He immediately looks up. It probably took him back in time to their early days. And Pam says, oh, I'm sorry. Jim Halpert doesn't work here anymore.
而且在节目结束前，我还想再坐在那个桌子后面一次。嗯，我太喜欢了。我是说，吉姆注意到了。他立刻抬起头。这大概把他带回了他们早期的时光。帕姆说，哦，对不起。吉姆·哈尔珀特不在这里工作了。
Yeah. And then Pam has a talking head. And you know, I want to play it because I love it so much, Jenna. This is one of my favorite Pam talking heads of the whole series. And I know a lot of people quote Pam's end final talking head, right?
对。然后帕姆有一个单人访谈。你知道，我想播放它，因为我太喜欢了，珍娜。这是整个系列中我最喜欢的帕姆单人访谈之一。我知道很多人都会引用帕姆最后的那个单人访谈，对吧？
That's a very famous one that gets quoted all the time. But this one is actually my favorite. Let's hear it. I didn't watch the whole documentary. After a few episodes, it was too painful. I kept wanting to scream at Pam. Let's hear it. It took me four years to get to him. It'd be great if people saw this documentary and learned from my mistakes. Not that I'm a tragic person, I'm really happy now, but it would just make my heart soar.
那是一个经常被引用的非常著名的访谈。但这个其实才是我的最爱。我们听听看。我没有看完整部纪录片。看了几集之后，太痛苦了。我一直想冲着帕姆尖叫。我们听听看。我花了四年时间才追到他。如果人们看到这部纪录片并从我的错误中吸取教训，那就太好了。倒不是说我是个悲剧人物，我现在真的很幸福，但如果有人看到这个，并且对自己说，坚强点，相信自己，爱自己，战胜恐惧，那么我的心一定会飞起来。
If someone out there saw this and she said to herself, be strong, trust yourself, love yourself, conquer your fears. Just go after what you want and act fast because life just isn't that long. Isn't that beautiful? It's beautiful writing. It's so beautiful.
去追求你想要的东西，迅速行动，因为生命真的没有那么长。这不是太美好了吗？文笔太美了。太美了。
It's just so great. Yeah. Well, it's beautiful writing and your performance was just so great. And you know, this talking head, I think it just hit me differently than the first time I heard it. Well, it's beautiful writing and your performance was just so great. And you know, this talking head, I think it just hit me differently than the first time I heard it. I was in my 30s.
简直太棒了。对。嗯，文笔很美，你的表现也太棒了。你知道，这个单人访谈，我觉得它给我的感触和第一次听它时完全不同。嗯，文笔很美，你的表现也太棒了。你知道，这个单人访谈，我觉得它给我的感触和第一次听它时完全不同。我当时30多岁。
And I haven't really, really listened to it in years. And now it just hits different at 53. It does. It sure does. It's the wisdom of someone who's had a lot of life go by. Yeah. Be strong, trust yourself, love yourself. I love it.
而且我已经好多年没有真正、真正地去听它了。现在到了53岁，感触完全不同了。确实如此。真的完全不同。这是一个经历了很多人生的人所拥有的智慧。对。坚强点，相信自己，爱自己。我太喜欢了。
I love it. Well, in the background of that talking head, you saw a lot of moments from Jim and Pam's relationship. You saw this one yo-yo moment with Jim kind of, that was us messing around on set. That was not in an episode. They just captured it. They just captured it.
我太喜欢了。嗯，在这个单人访谈的背景画面里，你看到了很多吉姆和帕姆感情中的时刻。你看到了这个摇摇板的时刻，吉姆有点……那是我们在片场瞎闹。那不在剧集里。他们只是捕捉到了。他们只是捕捉到了。
That was one of the many times that like, they would be rolling on us early, early on, and they just wanted us to do stuff, to capture as B-roll. And that was just one of the little things we came up with that Jim and Pam did. It was really cute. I loved seeing it, reminded me of those times. I loved seeing the passage of time.
那是他们很早就开始对准我们拍的众多时刻之一，他们只是想让我们做点事情，作为B面素材捕捉下来。这只是我们想出的吉姆和帕姆会做的小事情之一。真的很可爱。我喜欢看到它，让我想起了那些时光。我喜欢看到时间的流逝。
It really showed you how long you got to know these characters and how long we played these characters. Yeah. Well, the next talking head is Kevin. He says, if there's one thing I've learned through this whole experience, it's that if you film anybody long enough, they're going to do something stupid. It's only human natural. That's right. And then Angela and Dwight come in. Yes. Their honeymoon can wait, they say. I'm so curious what their honeymoon was. Same. I do want to play a clip from this scene.
它真的向你展示了你了解这些角色有多久，以及我们扮演这些角色有多久。对。好吧，接下来的单人访谈是凯文。他说，如果说通过整个经历我学到了什么，那就是如果你拍摄任何人足够久，他们都会做出一件蠢事。这是人之常情。没错。然后安吉拉和德怀特进来了。对。他们的蜜月可以等等，他们说。我太好奇他们的蜜月是怎么过的了。我也是。我真的很想播放这个场景的一个片段。
I've titled it, guess which line I had to ADR. Oh, okay. Let's hear it. Hey guys. Hi. Hey. What about the honeymoon? I don't know if the honeymoon can wait until tomorrow.
我给它起名叫，猜猜我哪句台词不得不后期配音（ADR）。哦，好吧。我们听听。嘿，伙计们。嗨。嘿。蜜月怎么办？我不知道蜜月能不能等到明天。
We wanted to hang out with you guys. I mean, when are we all going to be here together again? Is that the line, when are we all gonna be here together again? Yes. Lady, that is so crazy. I did not know that you had to ADR that line, but when I was watching this episode,
我们想和你们一起待会儿。我是说，我们什么时候才能所有人再聚在一起？是那句台词吗，“我们什么时候才能所有人再聚在一起”？对。天哪，太疯狂了。我不知道你那句台词必须得后期配音，但当我看到这一集时，
I thought to myself, I don't remember Angela ever getting through that line. You kept crying. Every time you said it, it got like stuck in your throat. You couldn getting through that line. You kept crying. Every time you said it, it got like stuck in your throat. You couldn't get that line out. I couldn't get the line. I was too emotional. And then I had to go back and do it in ADR.
我在心里想，我不记得安吉拉有哪次能把这句台词顺下来。你一直在哭。每次你说到它，它就像卡在你的喉咙里一样。你根本无法顺利把这句台词说完。你一直在哭。每次你说到它，它就像卡在你的喉咙里一样。你根本无法把这句台词说出口。我说不出这句台词。我太情绪化了。然后我不得不回去在后期配音里重新录。
So I actually got to see a little bit of the finale before it aired. Just that scene, you know? And it was so wild to me because when I went to do the ADR, we had wrapped, we had packed up our trailers, we had taken everything we wanted to take from the set, we were gone, it was done. And then they called me to do ADR at Universal.
所以我其实在播出前提前看了一点大结局。就那个场景，你知道吗？这对我来说太疯狂了，因为当我去录后期配音时，我们已经杀青了，我们已经收拾好拖车，我们已经拿走了所有想从片场拿的东西，我们已经走了，一切都结束了。然后他们叫我去环球影城做后期配音。
And for me, that was actually my last day of work on the office, was in this ADR booth. Saying that line, that you couldn't get out. That I couldn't get out. And I have a picture of me in the booth, because it says the office, you know? And that was my last day of work. Well, Dwight is going gonna propose a conference room meeting
对我来说，我在办公室工作的最后一天，其实是在这个后期配音室里。说着那句你当时说不出口的台词。我当时说不出口的台词。我有一张我在录音室里的照片，因为上面写着“办公室”，你知道吗？那就是我工作的最后一天。好吧，德怀特打算提议开个会议室会议
with Jim and Pam just for fun when he gets back from his honeymoon. But Jim says, actually we need to talk. Yeah, Pam and Jim go into Dwight's office and they share with him that they're gonna follow Athleap to Austin. Austin now? Yeah, and Dwight says, no, don't say it, you're fired, you're both fired. And Jim's like, Dwight, come on, don't end on a bad note.
和吉姆、帕姆一起，等他蜜月回来后就为了好玩。但吉姆说，其实我们需要谈谈。对，帕姆和吉姆走进德怀特的办公室，告诉他他们要跟着“奔向未来（Athleap）”去奥斯汀。现在去奥斯汀？对，德怀特说，不，别说，你被解雇了，你们俩都被解雇了。吉姆就说，德怀特，拜托，别以不好的结局收场。
But Dwight was saying that because now he can give them a severance package. Yeah, he says in true Dwight fashion, don't be an idiot. It's for the severance. I know. And he gives them one month for every year they've been at Dundermifflin. So that's pretty nice. How long do we think they've been there? Like seven or eight years? Are they gonna get like almost a year severance pay?
但德怀特这么说是因为现在他可以给他们一笔遣散费了。对，他用极其德怀特的方式说，别犯傻了。这是为了遣散费。我知道。他按照他们在邓德米夫林工作的年头，一年给他们一个月的遣散费。所以这挺不错的。大家觉得他们在那里待了多久？大概七八年？他们能拿到将近一年的遣散费吗？
That's what I thought. They're almost getting like a year's salary. That's a lot. Both of them. Both of them, exactly. Yeah. Jim also says, and you know what? If you're ever in Austin and and Dwight says, for what,
我也是这么想的。他们几乎能拿到相当于一年的薪水。这可不少。他们俩。他们俩，没错。对。吉姆还说，你知道吗？如果你什么时候去奥斯汀……德怀特说，去干嘛，
the art, the music, the incredible nightlife, no thank you. He's not interested. But if you're ever in the area, you'll always have a place to stay. In my barn. Yeah. Jim says, there it is. And then we have a Dwight talking head that I just really, really love. Yeah.
艺术、音乐、令人难以置信的夜生活，不用了谢谢。他没兴趣。但如果你什么时候去那个地区，你随时都有地方住。在我的谷仓里。对。吉姆说，就是这样。然后我们有一个德怀特的单人访谈，我真的、真的很喜欢。对。
He says, do I get along with my coworkers? Well, first of all, I don't have coworkers anymore. I have subordinates. And then he says he does get along with his subordinates. And he kind of talks about each of us. And there's little flashbacks to him spending time with us. Yeah, we learned that Meredith Palmer is the only person who knows how to properly headbang to Motorhead.
他说，我和同事相处得怎么样？首先，我再也没有同事了。我有下属。然后他说他和他的下属相处得很好。他讲述了我们每个人的情况。其中穿插了他和我们共度时光的小回忆。对，我们得知梅雷迪思·帕尔默是唯一一个知道如何伴随摩托头乐队（Motorhead）正确甩头的人。
Oscar is his godfather to his son. Angela, his former accountant, is now his wife. His top salesperson, Jim Halpert, was his best man at his wedding. And we find out who his best friend is. It's Pam. It's Pam. He says Pamela Beasley Halpert is my best friend.
奥斯卡是他儿子的教父。安吉拉，他以前的会计，现在成了他的妻子。他最出色的销售员吉姆·哈尔珀特是他在婚礼上的伴郎。我们还知道了谁是他最好的朋友。是帕姆。是帕姆。他说帕梅拉·比斯利·哈尔珀特是我最好的朋友。
So sweet. Meanwhile in the bullpen, there's a whole group that has gathered around Andy's old desk because they are watching his commencement speech for Cornell. And it's a big hit. Yeah. Daryl says, you know what, you did good, real good.
太甜了。与此同时在办公区，有一大群人聚集在安迪旧办公桌周围，因为他们在看他为康奈尔大学发表的毕业典礼演讲。这大受欢迎。对，达里尔说，你知道吗，你干得不错，真的很不错。
Andy says, thanks, Dad. I mean, Daryl. Yes. And then Andy has his famous talking head where he has the famous line, I wish there was a way to know you're in the good old days before you've actually left them. Yeah. And I think you can hear Ed's voice cracking
安迪说，谢谢，爸爸。我是说，达里尔。是的。然后安迪有了他著名的单人访谈，里面有那句名言：我希望在真正离开美好的旧时光之前，有一种方法能知道你正身处其中。对。我觉得你能听到爱德的声音在颤抖
when he says it. You can. You can hear the emotion in his voice right after he says that, and he says, someone should write a song about that. Yeah. Well, you know, Sam and Cassie and Jenna, Andy's famous line, I've just thought a lot about it because that's how I feel about our podcast
当他说出这句话的时候。你能听到。在他说完那句话后，你能听到他声音里的情绪，他说，应该有人为此写首歌。对。好吧，你知道，萨姆、卡西和珍娜，安迪的著名台词，我一直在想很多，因为这就是我对我们的播客的感受
Hmm, you know We're in the good old days right now. We are we had five years five years to get to do this What a gift and I want you to know that I've been aware since day one how special it was. Oh Sam There hasn't been a day that's gone by that I haven't appreciated this. And you know, it is almost exactly five years. Yeah, October 2019. Yep, to October 2024.
嗯，你知道的，我们现在正处于美好的旧时光里。我们确实是，我们有五年，五年的时间来做这件事。这是多么棒的一份礼物，我想让你们知道，从第一天起我就意识到了它是多么特别。哦，萨姆。没有一天我没有对此充满感激。而且你知道，这几乎正好是五年。对，2019年10月。没错，到2024年10月。
Well, this brings me to my last show and tell. And this isn't much, it's only something I think you guys would appreciate, but I saved my note cards from the first season of the podcast. Oh my goodness. And you each get one and I have a frame, but I didn't frame them yet because I wanted you to pick. I had a lot and I had to weed through. Here you go. Sam, you get to go first. You were with us go. Sam, you get to go first.
好吧，这让我想到了我的最后一个展示环节（show and tell）。这也没什么，只是我觉得你们会欣赏的东西，但我把播客第一季的便签卡留作纪念了。噢天哪。你们每人拿一张，我有一个相框，但我还没把它们装进去，因为我想让你们自己选。我有很多，我不得不挑拣一番。给你。萨姆，你先选。你和我们一起走。萨姆，你先选。
You were with us since day one and you get to go first. Here's what you get to choose. You get either, I watched the deleted scenes. Exclamation point. It's the first time I'd ever watched the deleted scenes. That was hot girl. Or you get Kelly still in an updo. Exclamation point. Cause we were tracking Kelly's hair.
你从第一天起就和我们在一起，你先选。这是你可以选择的。你可以选，我看了被删减片段。感叹号。这是我第一次看被删减片段。那是辣妹。或者你选，凯莉依然留着盘发。感叹号。因为我们在追踪凯莉的发型。
Okay. Or great jam moment at the end, and Jenna's skin looks flawless. Oh, I think I know which one I want. Diversity day. This one. The peep shot. Asterix, through the blinds, Michael playing with his truck.
好的。或者，结尾处很棒的吉姆和帕姆时刻，而且珍娜的皮肤看起来无瑕疵。哦，我想我知道我要哪个了。多元化日。这个。偷窥镜头。星号，透过百叶窗，迈克尔在玩他的卡车。
So busy. Healthcare. Eight minutes and fourteen seconds. Pan left her salad on the table. Exclamation point. COLLEEN O'BRIEN That led to a very fun conversation. COLLEEN Yes. John says D White.
太忙了。医疗保健。八分十四秒。帕姆把沙拉忘在桌上了。感叹号。科琳·奥布赖恩 这引发了一场非常有趣的对话。科琳 是的。约翰说D·怀特。
COLLEEN Ooh, D White. COLLEEN So there you go. These are D White. Mm-hmm. So there you go. These are all from the early podcast days. It's gotta be John says D White. Okay. All right. I have a frame for you.
科琳 哦，D·怀特。科琳 所以，就这样。这些都是D·怀特。嗯-hmm。所以，就这样。这些都是早期播客时期的东西。肯定得选“约翰说D·怀特”。好的。好吧。我给你准备了个相框。
Thank you. All right. That leaves Cassie. I'll come pick. I know which one I would pick for you, Cassie. I'm curious if you'll pick the same one that I have on my mind. I think I'm gonna go peep shot.
谢谢。好吧。轮到卡西了。我来挑。我知道我会为你选哪个，卡西。我很好奇你是不是会选我心里想的那张。我想我要选偷窥镜头。
The peep shot? Peep shot, I am surprised! Which one were you thinking I was gonna pick? I would have given you, I watched the deleted scenes because of all the late night emails that you get from Angela with time codes for deleted scenes. Yeah, I was thinking that was one you're probably thinking about,
偷窥镜头？偷窥镜头，我很惊讶！你以为我会选哪个？我本来会给你选“我看了被删减片段”，因为安吉拉给你发了那么多深夜电子邮件，里面带有被删减片段的时间码。对，我想那可能是你大概会想到的，
but I like how random this is. The peep shot I got made fun of quite a bit for because it's called a spy shot. But I thought it was called a peep shot. I also like I put in quotes, so busy. So busy. He's so busy. All right, Jenna, that leaves you, Miss. I'd like the one that notates my flawless skin, please. I thought you might.
但我喜欢这个有多随机。我选的那个偷窥镜头被开玩笑取笑过好几次，因为它叫间谍镜头。但我以为它叫偷窥镜头。我也喜欢我加上了引号的，“太忙了”。太忙了。他太忙了。好吧，珍娜，轮到你了，女士。我想要那个标注我皮肤无瑕疵的，谢谢。我就知道你会。
All right. There you go. All right. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. That's the end of my show and tell for the finale. I want to note that, Cassie, you decorated everything. Sam, you got us a John Wick-themed drawing.
好吧。给你。好的，谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。这就是我关于大结局的展示环节。我要指出的是，卡西，你把一切都装饰得很漂亮。萨姆，你给我们弄了一张《疾速追杀》（John Wick）主题的画。
Angela, you've given us your note cards. I've shown up empty-handed to our finale. I hate to drop the big old sea bomb here at the end of the finale, but it's, you know, these are some of the details that you don't have the bandwidth for anymore. And it's been on my mind like what is my thing that I could bring or what could I do and we are planning a little team dinner. Yes and you're planning it. You're picking the restaurant. That's the things people don't see. It's true but I just I I guess I do want to take this moment, since we're in this moment, to just say again, a lot of life has happened in five years, particularly in this last year for me.
安吉拉，你把你的便签卡送给了我们。我两手空空地来参加我们的大结局。我不喜欢在大结局的尾声抛出一个重磅的“C”炸弹，但是，你知道，这些是有些你不再有精力去应付的细节。我一直在想，我能带什么东西，或者我能做什么，我们正在计划一个小型团队晚宴。是的，而且是你计划的。你选的餐厅。这就是人们看不到的事情。确实如此，但我只是，我想借此机会，既然我们正处于这个时刻，再次表达，在过去的五年里，人生经历了很多，尤其是对我来说，在过去这一年里。
And coming here each week and doing this. It gave me purpose and joy, and I thank you all from the bottom of my heart, and I thank our Office Ladies community as well. I love this podcast. I love being here, and I love you all. Well, we love you too, and we're just so thankful, Jenna. We're so thankful. You are doing great, and we're just so thankful, Jenna. We're so thankful.
每周来到这里做这件事。它给了我目标和快乐，我从心底里感谢你们所有人，我也感谢我们的“办公室女士”社区。我爱这个播客。我喜欢来到这里，我爱你们所有人。嗯，我们也爱你，我们太感激了，珍娜。我们太感激了。你做得很好，我们太感激了，珍娜。我们太感激了。
You are doing great and we're so thankful. I am doing great. You're doing fucking great. Doing great. I lifted weights this morning. Yes. Yes. Get it, Jenna.
你做得很好，我们太感激了。我确实做得很好。你他妈做得太棒了。做得太棒了。我今天早上举重了。是的。是的。加油，珍娜。
I sure did. Can I say that- 20 pounds on my biceps, everybody. I was going to do this weight training class with Jenna, but I can't lift as much as her. I have no upper body strength. So the lady is very nice. She's like, Angela, maybe you and I should do,
我当然做了。我能说——我的二头肌负重20磅，各位。我本来打算和珍娜一起去上这个力量训练课，但我举不起和她一样重的重量。我完全没有上半身力量。所以这位女士非常好。她说，安吉拉，也许你和我应该做，
like, until I can catch up. Start with some baby weights. Yeah, baby weights. There was a lot of evidence that weight training, specifically, would really help me with some of my Side effects from some of the medicines I still have to take. It's a shame We're on the last episode because baby weights is such a good nickname Josh got me some two pounds and five pounds. So look out. I love you baby weights
直到我能赶上。从婴儿重量（轻量级）开始。对，婴儿重量。有很多证据表明，力量训练，特别是力量训练，真的能帮我缓解一些我仍然不得不服用的药物带来的副作用。真遗憾我们到了最后一集，因为“婴儿重量”是个这么棒的外号。乔什给我准备了一些2磅和5磅的哑铃。所以小心了。我爱你，婴儿重量。
pounds and five pounds, so look out. I love you baby weights. Aw. Well, let's see, where are we? We're in the middle of some very sentimental sharing, but so is everybody else in the office. How about that for a transition? I like it. Oscar has one of my favorite final talking heads.
磅和5磅的哑铃，所以小心了。我爱你，婴儿重量。噢。好吧，让我们看看，我们到哪儿了？我们正处于一些非常感性的分享中，但办公室里的其他人也是如此。这个转场怎么样？我喜欢。奥斯卡拥有我最喜欢的最后单人访谈之一。
For me, it's really between Oscar and Ellie. I love that Oscar says, you take something ordinary like a piece of paper. It's not much, but if you see it in the right way, and he's folding a piece of paper, he says, and that's what you did with this documentary, and he holds up a little origami swan.
对我来说，真的在奥斯卡和艾莉之间很难抉择。我喜欢奥斯卡说，你拿走一个像一张纸这样普通的东西。它其实没什么，但如果你换个正确的角度来看它，他一边折纸一边说，这就是你对这部纪录片所做的事情，他举起了一只小折纸天鹅。
But then he says, but seriously, you made a nine-year documentary and you couldn't once show me doing my origami? He found a way to get it in there though. He did. And now we're gonna see Creed come out of the bathroom with no shirt on, he's brushing his teeth. He clearly is living there again.
但接着他说，不过说真的，你拍了一个九年的纪录片，就不能哪怕一次让我展示一下我的折纸吗？不过他还是找到了办法把它塞进去了。他确实做到了。现在我们看到克里德光着膀子从洗手间出来，他在刷牙。他显然又住在那里了。
Yes, it brings up a lot of questions like I guess we don't use that closet or open that door. Ever. Everyone's very surprised to see him, but also very happy because he's going to get his guitar out and he's going to sing for us. Yes. We'll have more to say about Creed playing the guitar
是的，这引发了很多问题，比如我猜我们不用那个衣橱或者不开那扇门。永远不用。大家看到他都很惊讶，但也都很高兴，因为他要把吉他拿出来，为我们唱歌。是的。关于克里德为我们所有人弹吉他这件事，
for all of us a little bit later. Yes, we will. Now Jim is going to have his talking head. He says, imagine going back and watching a tape of your life. You could see yourself change and make mistakes and grow up. You could watch yourself fall in love, watch yourself become a husband, become a father. You guys gave that to me. And that's an amazing gift.
我们稍后会有更多要说的。是的，我们会说的。现在吉姆要有他的单人访谈了。他说，想象一下回去观看你一生活动的录像带。你可以看到自己改变、犯错和长大。你可以看着自己坠入爱河，看着自己成为丈夫，成为父亲。你们把这送给了我。这是一个惊人的礼物。
I feel like there was a lot of John in this talking head. Look, what's on my document. I put asterisk. I really saw John Krasinski in this talking head. Yeah. That's John. Yeah. All of those things happened to him in the course of this show. They did. It's true. In this moment, we're kind of flashing back and forth between Creed playing
我觉得这个单人访谈里有很多约翰的影子。看，我的文件上有什么。我加了星号。我真的在这个单人访谈里看到了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。对。那是约翰。对。所有这些事情都在这个节目的历程中发生在他身上。确实如此。真的。在此刻，我们不断闪回切换，一会儿是克里德在弹
his song and people having different conversations, different moments. Different talking heads. Yes. For example, Kevin is going to become so overcome with emotion, he tells Oscar he might be gay. And I love Oscar. You're not gay. I know.
他的歌，一会儿是人们在进行不同的谈话、不同的时刻。不同的单人访谈。是的。例如，凯文变得如此情绪激动，他告诉奥斯卡他可能是个同性恋。我喜欢奥斯卡说。你不是同性恋。我知道。
Kevin is just feeling a lot of feelings. Erin is now going to have a talking head where she says, how did you do it? How did you capture what it was really like? How we felt and how we made each other laugh and how we got through the day? How did you do it? How did you capture what it was really like? How we felt and how we made each other laugh and how we got through the day? How did you do it? Also how do cameras work? I love her talking head.
凯文只是感触良多。艾琳现在有一个单人访谈，她说，你们是怎么做到的？你们是怎么捕捉到那种真实感觉的？我们当时的感受，我们是如何让彼此欢笑的，以及我们是如何度过每一天的？你们是怎么做到的？你们是怎么捕捉到那种真实感觉的？我们当时的感受，我们是如何让彼此欢笑的，以及我们是如何度过每一天的？你们是怎么做到的？还有摄像机是怎么工作的？我喜欢她的单人访谈。
I know it's really sweet. Now we have a fan question that I've placed here for a specific reason. It's from Lillian W. in Ontario, Canada, who wrote Justice for Angela. I feel so badly that Angela Martin does not get a talking head in the finale. Can someone explain why? Was there one that was filmed and maybe didn't make the final cut? Angela, how do you feel about this? Well, there were several.
我知道这真的很温馨。现在我们有一个粉丝的问题，我把它放在这里是有特定原因的。它来自加拿大安大略省的莉莲·W.，她写道：“为安吉拉讨回公道”。我觉得安吉拉·马丁在大结局里没有单人访谈太让人遗憾了。谁能解释一下为什么？是不是拍了但没有剪进最终正片里？安吉拉，你对此有什么感觉？嗯，拍了好几个。
You know, on the DVD and the deleted scenes, there are so much footage that didn't make it. And it wasn't just my talking head. Toby also has one that's really funny. But I did have one. And you know, when it aired and my talking head wasn't in it, I was a little bummed, but it was also my wedding day. I had a lot of fun stuff in this episode. Yeah.
你知道的，在DVD和被删减片段里，有很多没有播出的素材。不只是我的单人访谈。托比也有一个非常搞笑的访谈。但我确实有一个。你知道的，当它播出时我的单人访谈没有在里面，我有点小失落，但这也是我的婚礼当天。在这个剧集里我有很多好玩的内容。对。
But here it is if you'd like to hear it. I would like to hear it. Ten years ago a doctor told me the muscles in my cheeks had atrophied from lack of smiling. So I had exercises to do at bedtime. It helped some, but now I'm smiling all the time and I don't even notice. So yeah, I think I'm less of a total bitch now. That's very funny. And I have a picture when I was looking through my digital clutter. Greg Daniels emailed me after I did my talking head, and he took a picture of me from the side. You can see the camera. You can see Brian Whittle operating the boom, and I'm facing camera giving the talking head over by accounting.
但如果你想听，它就在这儿。我很想听听。十年前，一位医生告诉我，由于缺乏微笑，我脸颊上的肌肉已经萎缩了。所以我必须在睡前做一些练习。这起到了一些作用，但现在我一直在笑，甚至自己都没注意到。所以，是的，我觉得我现在没那么讨厌了。这太搞笑了。当我翻看我的数码杂物时，我有一张照片。格里格·戴尔斯在我做完单人访谈后给我发了封电子邮件，他从侧面拍了我一张照片。你能看到摄像机。你能看到布赖恩·惠特尔在操作吊杆麦克风，而我面对着摄像机，在会计部旁边做着单人访谈。
What a neat picture. Yeah. Darryl is going to say, every day when I came into work, all I wanted to do was leave. So why in the world does it feel so hard to leave right now? And then there was a scene in the deleted scenes. It's not even in the shooting draft. I feel like this is one of those moments that happened on the day. This was part of those rewrites of the script
多整洁的一张照片啊。对。达里尔要说的是，每天我来上班时，我唯一的愿望就是离开。所以为什么这会儿离开感觉这么难呢？然后被删减片段里有一个场景。它甚至不在拍摄初稿里。我觉得这是当场发生的那些时刻之一。这是剧本重写的一部分
that we mentioned last week, how Greg was adding scenes, taking scenes away. So they were not in the sort of shooting draft. But you share what it is. This was originally Greg's idea for the ending shot. Yeah. So Darryl is going to ask everyone, who's idea for the ending shot. Yeah. So, Daryl is going to ask everyone, who's been here the longest?
我们上周提到过，格里格是如何添加场景、删减场景的。所以它们不在那种拍摄初稿里。但你来分享一下它是什么。这最初是格里格对结尾镜头的想法。对。所以，达里尔要问每个人，谁待的时间最长？
And everyone starts to share their stories. The scene was so special to the cast. Everyone decides the person or thing that's been there the longest is that plant. Planty. Planty. Let's hear this clip. Who's been here the longest?
然后每个人开始分享他们的故事。这个场景对演员们来说太特别了。每个人都认为待得最久的人或东西是那株植物。小绿（Planty）。小绿。我们听听这段音频。谁待的时间最长？
It was me. Oh, it's me now. I started two days after Stanley. Why do I remember working here before Stanley? I'm pretty sure I was here before you, though. I'll tell you who's been here the longest. That poor plant. Planty.
是我。哦，现在是我了。我比斯坦利晚两天开始。为什么我记得在斯坦利之前我就在这里工作了？我很确定我比你早到这里。我来告诉你谁待得最久。那株可怜的植物。小绿。
Wait, I don't remember that plant before. That plant is a survivor. It's time for him to move on. Let's set him free. Or her. Seriously, come on. I'm just saying. Let's get him some real sunlight once and for all.
等等，我不记得以前有那株植物。那株植物是个幸存者。是时候让他前进了。让我们放他自由。或者她。说真的，拜托。我只是说说而已。一劳永逸地给他晒晒真正的阳光吧。
Yeah. Somebody give me a hand. I'm on it. Oh my gosh, we're really gonna do this. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yeah! Yes! Yes!
对。谁来帮个忙。我来。噢天哪，我们真的要这么做吗？对。对。对。是的。对！是的！
Peace and distance! Peace and distance! Go ahead. Don't overpack the dirt! Ah, amateurs. Office plant. Office plant. Office plant. Office plant, office plant, office plant, office plant, office plant.
和平与距离！和平与距离！去吧。别把泥土填得太满！啊，业余选手。办公室植物。办公室植物。办公室植物。办公室植物，办公室植物，办公室植物，办公室植物，办公室植物。
Yeah! I remember shooting that and I have so many pictures from all of us outside. Yes, it was a really special moment for the cast. We all stand around planty and it's just one of the moments I remember so vividly. So originally, the idea was that the episode was going to end, like the final shot of the episode was going to be of Plante. And the idea was just like that this thing
耶！我记得拍摄那个场景，我有好多我们在外面的照片。是的，对演员们来说这是一个非常特别的时刻。我们都围在小绿身边，这绝对是我记忆中最鲜活的时刻之一。所以最初的想法是，这集的结尾将是，剧集的最后一个镜头将是关于小绿的。这个想法就像是这个东西
was gonna like continue to grow. Yes. You know, after a lot of us have moved on. I went to the very final line of the script for the shooting draft and this is what it says. B-roll of the replanted office plant with Dunder Mifflin behind it as the sun comes up over the parking lot.
会继续生长。是的。你知道的，在我们中的许多人离开之后。我查阅了拍摄初稿剧本的最后一句话，它是这么写的：重新种植的办公室植物的B面素材，背景是邓德米夫林，太阳在停车场徐徐升起。
But we're gonna end a slightly different way. We're gonna have some more talking heads. We're going to see Creed get arrested. Meredith and Phyllis are going to share. And this is all kind of intercut with scenes of us gathering up our things and leaving for the final time. Yes. If you go to 48 minutes and 14 seconds,
但我们要以稍微不同的方式收尾。我们会有更多的单人访谈。我们会看到克里德被捕。梅雷迪思和菲利斯将进行分享。这一切都与我们收拾东西最后一次离开的场景交织在一起。是的。如果你看到48分14秒，
that shot of all of us leaving was actually the last shot we filmed together as a cast. Yeah, so Pam has the final talking head, and when the one-liner, which is the schedule of scenes for an episode comes out, you know I would love to read it. I saw that the very last thing that was scheduled for the last day of shooting was Pam's talking head. I went to John's trailer and I said, John, did you see the one-liner? And I showed him and I said, I don't want to be here alone.
我们所有人离开的那个镜头，实际上是我们作为演员一起拍摄的最后一个镜头。对，所以帕姆有最后的单人访谈，当通告单（一集场景的日程安排）出来时，你知道我一定会去读的。我看到拍摄最后一天的日程安排的最后一项是帕姆的单人访谈。我去了约翰的拖车，我说，约翰，你看到通告单了吗？我给他看了，我说，我不想一个人呆在那里。
I don't want to be here all by myself. Yeah. I want us to end together. And John said, we have to end together. So we went together to Ken Quapus and Greg, and they said, oh, we thought it would be really poetic to end the show by filming the very last moment last, but we hear you. So here's what we'll do. We're gonna film your talking head,
我不想一个人留在这里。对。我想我们一起结束。约翰说，我们必须一起结束。所以我们一起去找肯·夸普斯和格雷格，他们说，哦，我们觉得以拍摄最后一个人离开作为全剧的收尾会很有诗意，但我们听到你们的心声了。所以我们这样办。我们要拍你的特写访谈，
if everyone doesn't mind waiting, and then when you're finished, we will film that final B-roll of everyone leaving the office and of Pam taking the watercolor off the wall. How does that sound? And John and I were like, yes, we need to all be together when you say, that's a rap on The Office.
如果大家不介意稍等一会儿的话，等你拍完，我们会去拍最后那个所有人都离开办公室，以及帕姆把水彩画从墙上取下来的花絮镜头。大家觉得怎么样？我和约翰都说，太好了，当你们说出“《办公室》杀青”时，我们需要所有人都在场。
That's a series rap. I'm like, I don't want to be here by myself. Yeah, yeah. And that's what they did. And we were all so thankful. And you know, I have video of all of us watching you do that talking head. I'm finally going to post it. I've been saving it for years. And it was just really moving that when they said that's a wrap, that we all we all just poured into the bullpen. Our crew, our writers were all standing around waiting, watching with us on the stage. And we all just hugged and cried and all of us. Well we did that exit way more times than we needed to. I know.
这是全剧杀青。我说，我不想一个人待在这里。对，对。他们就是这么做的。我们都非常感激。而且你知道，我有我们所有人看着你做那个特写访谈的视频。我终于要把它发出来了。我存了好几年了。当他们说杀青的那一刻，大家一古脑儿涌进开放式办公区，真的非常感人。我们的剧组人员、编剧们都站在周围等待，和我们在现场一起看着。我们所有人都拥抱在一起，哭了起来，所有人。其实我们走出办公室的次数比实际需要的要多得多。我知道。
And Ken Quapus said after about like six times, he turned to Greg and he said, Greg, I think we got it. We're done. And Greg said, what do we do? And Ken said, well, we have to say, that's a wrap, but I think you should say it, Greg." So he said, I'll have him do it one more time, okay?
肯·夸普斯拍了大约六次之后，转头对格雷格说，格雷格，我觉得我们拍到了。我们完成了。格雷格说，接下来我们做什么？肯说，嗯，我们得说，“杀青了”，但我觉得应该由你来说，格雷格。”所以他说，“我让他们再拍一次，好吗？”
And Greg was like, okay. So we did it one more time. And I remember every time we would leave, we would crowd, all of us would crowd into that little area by the elevator. And we would stand there for a beat and then you would hear them say, all right, reset, back to one, going again. And there was always this very pregnant pause. Like once we got to like take three, take four, you're like, how many times can we do this? And then finally we were all standing there in that like pregnant pause.
格雷格就说，好吧。于是我们又拍了一次。我记得每次我们离开时，大家都会挤在那片靠近电梯的小区域里。我们会站在那里停顿一会儿，然后你就会听到他们说，“好了，重置，回到原位，再来一次。”总是会有这样一段意味深长的停顿。就像我们拍到第三条、第四条的时候，你会想，我们到底能拍多少次？最后我们都站在那里，经历着那段意味深长的停顿。
I was heard. And we heard Greg's voice. Yeah. And finally we were all standing there in that like pregnant pause and we heard Greg's voice. He said, cut. That's a wrap. That's a series wrap on the office. And then we all came out from that area and we were surprised by our crew that they had
我听到了。我们听到了格雷格的声音。对。最后我们都站在那里，经历着那段意味深长的停顿，我们听到了格雷格的声音。他说，卡。杀青了。这是《办公室》全剧杀青。然后我们都从那个区域走了出来，惊喜地发现我们的剧组人员
had gather. Yeah. Every time we walked to the elevator bank, I was next to Phyllis, because when you watch the scene, Dwight goes to help with the plant, and I'm kind of left perched on top of front reception. It's pretty high. And Phyllis and Oscar would help me down. So I would walk out with them, and Phyllis and I would hold hands waiting to see if we would go again. Mm. Yeah. That was pretty emotional.
已经聚在那里了。对。每次我们走向电梯区时，我都挨着菲利斯，因为当你看到那个镜头时，德怀特去帮忙搬植物，而我差不多是坐在前台接待处边缘的。挺高的。菲利斯和奥斯卡会扶我下来。所以我就会和他们一起走出去，菲利斯会拉着我的手，等着看我们是否还要再拍一次。嗯。对。那真的挺感人的。
But the episode ends after Pam's talking head. Yes. Pam famously says there's a lot of beauty in ordinary things. Isn't that kind of the point? Well, that's just, that was Greg's philosophy of this show. It was meant to mine the beauty in ordinary day-to-day life. It's beautiful. Yeah, that's what we were shining a spotlight on.
但这一集在帕姆的特写访谈之后就结束了。对。帕姆有句名言，平凡的生活中蕴含着许多美好。这不正是关键所在吗？嗯，那只是，那是格雷格这部剧的哲学。它的初衷就是去发掘平凡日常生活中的美。太美了。对，这就是我们所聚焦的光芒。
So amazing. And I loved shooting this talking head. I was talking to Ken Quapus. That's who was sitting across from me in the job when Jim finally asked Pam on a date. And that's who I got to deliver my final talking head to. And it's very meaningful to me. I love that we see Steve again one last time. Yeah, I love that we get to see Michael and he's hanging hope in a frame. Mm-hmm, that's right. And then that sort of morphs into our actual building.
太棒了。而且我很喜欢拍这个特写访谈。我当时在和肯·夸普斯说话。吉姆最终约帕姆出去约会时，就是他坐在我对面。这就是听我做最后一次特写访谈的人。这对我有很深的意义。我很高兴我们最后一次看到了史蒂夫。对，我很高兴我们能看到迈克尔，他正在把希望挂在相框里。嗯，没错。然后这就演变成了我们现实中的大楼。
They sort of go from the watercolor to the actual Dundermiflin. And I love how plain it is. I love it's literally the most ordinary looking building you could imagine. And that was our building. And Pam gets to take her painting home. And Jenna took it home too. It's in my living room. Well, guys, that is Finale Part 2, but we're not finished yet because from the moment we started this podcast, we knew exactly how we wanted to end it. We did.
他们从水彩画过渡到了真正的邓德米夫林。我喜欢它的简朴。我能想象到的最普通的大楼就是它本来的样子。那是我们的大楼。帕姆把她的画带回家了。珍娜也带回家了。它就在我的客厅里。好了，各位，这就是第二季大结局，但我们还没结束，因为从我们开始这个播客的那一刻起，我们就确切地知道我们想以什么方式结束它。我们确实知道。
And my neighbor is coming through for us because we reached out to Creed Bratton and we said, Creed, will you sing your song on our podcast All the Faces? That's the perfect way to say goodbye to this re-watch. And he said yes and he's here today. So give us a second which to you will literally feel like one second and he's gonna set up and we'll chat with him. Well here is our special guest we've been talking about. We are so excited. In fact, our very first guest in our new space here to celebrate the end of the rewatch with us is Creed Bratton. Hi Creed. Hi ladies. Thanks for having me. Yes, thank you. You are here. You are going to be leaving tomorrow.
我的邻居一直在支持我们，因为我们联系了克里德·布拉顿，我们说，克里德，你愿意在我们的播客上唱你的歌《所有的面孔》吗？这是对这次重温之旅最好的告别方式。他说好，他今天就在这里。所以给我们一点时间，对你们来说真的就像一秒钟，他要调试一下，然后我们会和他聊天。这就是我们一直在谈论的特我们非常兴奋。事实上，为了和我们一起庆祝重温之旅的结束，我们新空间里的第一位嘉宾就是克里德·布拉顿。嗨，克里德。嗨，女士们。谢谢你们邀请我。对，谢谢你。你在这里。你明天就要走了。
We got you on your last day in town. Tell everybody where you're going. I'll be in Ireland and England, Norway, Denmark, Holland, Slovakia and Czechoslovakia. On tour. On tour for the month of October. Amazing. We're gonna put all of your tour dates in our Instagram.
我们在你离开镇上的最后一天抓住了你。告诉大家你要去哪里。我将去爱尔兰和英国、挪威、丹麦、荷兰、斯洛伐克和捷克斯洛伐克。在巡演。十月份进行巡演。太棒了。我们要把你的所有巡演日期都发到我们的Instagram上。
Oh, thank you. Yes. Thank you. And then we're so thrilled because you're here today. This was actually something Jenna and I have talked about for years, and then you brought it back up to us, Creed. What did I call it accidentally that time? And will you tell everybody you really have called accidentally?
哦，谢谢。对。谢谢。我们非常高兴你今天能来。这其实是珍娜和我谈论过很多年的事，后来你又向我们提起过，克里德。那次我无意中怎么称呼它来着？你能不能告诉大家你当时是真的无意中打过电话？
You know, online, people think that we set that up. No, no, folks. No, you really just called. Fans of the Office Ladies people think that we set that up. No, no folks. No, you really just called. Fans of the Office Ladies, I just called to check in because I was curious to see where you guys were on the show and I thought, you know, I'll call Pumpkin and check in. And you did. And I did and then you guys were on the air. So no, that's honest to God. And I know Creed lies, but myself as Creed, I don't lie.
你知道，网民们以为那是我们安排的。不，不，各位。不，你真的只是打了个电话。《办公室女士》的粉丝们以为那是我们安排的。不，不，各位。不，你真的只是打了个电话。《办公室女士》的粉丝们，我只是打电话来问候一下，因为我很好奇你们在看剧的哪个阶段，我想，你知道，我给小南瓜打个电话问候一下。你真的打了。我打了，然后你们正在直播。所以不，那是上帝作证的实话。我知道克里德会撒谎，但作为现实中的克里德，我绝不撒谎。
That's true. That the character does. Well, this song is one that you sang on the finale. That's right. And tell us how that came about, because it's such a great story. It's a great story. It's probably about, I don't know how long it was before we
那是真的。剧中角色会撒谎。这首歌是你在大结局中唱的那首。没错。给我们讲讲这是怎么发生的，因为这是一个非常棒的故事。这是一个极好的故事。大概是，我不知道在我们
did the table read. You know before we did the table read, a month and a half, months, at least over a month. So I'm in my trailer and we've all been talking, how are we going to possibly end this show, this amazing show that we all love? What are we going to do for the finale? It's got to be amazing. Now, Greg Daniels came back to write the ship and do it with us, you know. So I'm sitting in my trailer and there's a knock on the door and it's a PA. Now you know Rain and I have trained them never to look us in the eye.
进行剧本围读之前多久。你知道在剧本围读之前，一个半月，几个月，至少一个多月。当时我在我的房车里，我们一直在讨论，我们怎么可能结束这部剧，这部我们都深爱的精彩剧集？大结局我们要拍什么？必须得非常精彩。现在，格雷格·丹尼尔斯回来收拾残局并和我们一起完成这部剧，你知道的。所以我正坐在房车里，有人敲门，是个制片助理。现在你知道雷恩和我已经训练过他们绝不能直视我们的眼睛。
Stop it. No, don't. I opened the door. To the production assistant. His head production assistant, they help us out on the show. So his eyes are like, oh, Mr. Bratton. I said, speak up. He went, oh, Mr. Bratton. I said, not so loud. And so he, I said, what do you want? He said, uh, Greg wants to see you in his office. I said, why didn't you say so? So I push him out of the way.
别这样。不，别说了。我打开门。对制片助理。他的首席制片助理，他们在剧组里帮我们忙。所以他的眼神就像，哦，布拉顿先生。我说，大声点。他结巴着说，哦，布拉顿先生。我说，没那么大声。于是他，我说，你想干什么？他说，呃，格雷格想见你，在他的办公室。我说，你怎么不早说？于是我把他推开。
I stopped it. And I charge, I charge, what's up boss? I always said that with Gray, what's up boss? He said, oh Creed, oh Creed. I'm asking all the actors how you think your character should lead the show. So I said, well I wrote this song called All the Faces in 1970 right after I left the grassroots.
我打断了他。我冲了进去，冲了进去，怎么了老大？我跟格雷格总是这么说，怎么了老大？他说，哦，克里德，哦，克里德。我正在问所有的演员，你们觉得你们的角色应该如何离开这部剧。所以我说，我在1970年离开草根乐队后写了一首歌叫《所有的面孔》。
I'm sitting in my house in Ramirez Canyon. My wife is in the other room, and my daughter, Ami, is in their little bassinet, and I'm playing guitar by the fire. And she yells at me, she said, that's a beautiful song. Who wrote that? And I said, I think I just did. So I tell Greg this, he said, well, let me hear it.
我正坐在米雷斯峡谷的房子里。我妻子在另一个房间，我女儿艾米在他们的小摇篮里，我正坐在壁炉旁弹吉他。她冲我喊道，这是一首好听的歌。谁写的？我说，我想刚刚是我写的。所以我把这个告诉了格雷格，他说，好吧，让我听听。
And I just told him, I think I should be playing this song in Poor Richards, and all the cast, all you guys walk through, we see your faces and I'm singing this song. He hears the song, I can see he's moved. I don't hear another word. Cut to a month and a half later, we get on a bus, we go over to over Universal, right? Everybody's there, the brass, NBC and Universal, and the photographers, and the press. Big finale, table read. Big deal.
我只是告诉他，我觉得我应该在穷理查酒吧唱这首歌，所有的演员，你们所有人走过去，我们看着你们的面孔，而我正在唱这首歌。他听了这首歌，我看得出他被打动了。我没听到他说别的。镜头快进到一个半月后，我们上了一辆大巴，去了环球影城，对吧？所有人都到了，高管们，NBC和环球影城的高管，还有摄影师和记者。大结局，剧本围读。大事。
Yeah. And a read in the finale, and we're going through with our yellow markers, marking where we're gonna talk. And I just have this little bit at the end, and I come and turn the page over and says, Creed sings his original song, All the Faces. That's how you found out.
对。在大结局围读时，我们拿着黄色荧光笔，标记我们要说话的地方。我只有最后一点台词，当我翻过页子时，上面写着：克里德演唱他的原创歌曲《所有的面孔》。这就是你发现的时候。
That's how I found out, at the table read. That's the first time I knew I was gonna get to it. Because I thought, nah, I tried, but it's not happening. And then there was what's happening and I almost cried and I looked around, oh my, and then I started panicking. I thought, oh my god, I don't have my guitar. And there's that PA that I gave a bad time to. He looks, he hands me my guitar, but he looks like he's gonna drop it, messing with me, you know? Paybacks a bit, folks. So, Greg had arranged for your guitar to be there? Yes, yes, yes.
这就是我发现的时候，在剧本围读会上。那是第一次我知道我将得到这个机会。因为我想，不，我试过了，但这不会发生。然后事情发生了，我差点哭了，我环顾四周，天哪，然后我开始惊慌失措。我想，哦，天哪，我没有带吉他。然后就是那个被我整过的制片助理。他看着我，把吉他递给我，但他看起来好像要把它摔了，在跟我开玩笑呢，你知道吗？风水轮流转，各位。所以，格雷格安排了你的吉他在那里？是的，是的，是的。
Oh my gosh. And I sang it. And of course, and the executives are there and there's not a dry eye in the house, not at all. And by the way, we know these people eat their own, for God's sake. So... You even made the execs cry, Creed. I made the execs cry. So, that's the execs cry. So that's the story. So then I played it. One more story.
哦，天哪。我唱了。当然，高管们也在场，全场没有一个人不落泪的，一点也没有。顺便说一句看，我们都知道这些人为了自身利益会不择手段，天哪。所以……你甚至把高管们都弄哭了，克里德。我把高管们弄哭了。所以，这就是故事。然后我弹了。还有一个故事。
When we were recording it, Brian couldn't get the boom right because it was in the shot. And John Krasinski says, he's sitting next to you. And he says, Creed, I'll put the microphone under my arm. So he puts this long telescopic shotgun mic underneath his arm right out here. So it's picking up my guitar. So thank you, John telescopic, you know, shotgun mic underneath his arm right out here so it's picking up my guitar. So thank you, John, for recording my guitar. Yeah. What was that like for you playing for us in that scene? I mean, it was very emotional for us. It was emotional for me too. I had to just tie it together and get real professional because I could have broken up. But I just, all I was, I was just,
当我们录制的时候，布赖恩拿不准吊杆麦克风的位置，因为它入镜了。约翰·克拉辛斯基说，他就坐在你旁边。他说，克里德，我把麦克风夹在胳膊底下。于是他把这个长长的伸缩式枪式麦克风夹在胳膊底下，就在这里。这样它就能收到我的吉他声了。所以谢谢你，约翰伸缩式，你知道的，把枪式麦克风夹在胳膊底下，就在这里，这样它就能收到我的吉他声了。所以谢谢你，约翰，帮我录下了吉他。对。你在那个场景中为我们弹奏时是什么感觉？我的意思是，这对我们来说非常感性。对我来说也很感性。我不得不克制自己，表现得非常专业，因为我本可能会崩溃的。但我只是，我所做的一切就是，
I'm in my head, I'm not paying any attention. I'm just singing the song. Right, well we- But it was a big deal. It was a big deal. And it changed my life. Having that song get out and go viral like it still sells and still people come to the show
我在脑子里想别的，我什么都没注意。我只是在唱歌。对，好吧，我们——但这可是件大事。这是件大事。它改变了我的生活。这首歌传开并在网络上爆红，到现在它依然在热卖，人们依然来到演出现场
and they want to hear that song. It's a, what a gift, what a gift. Beautiful song Creed. And we are so incredibly fortunate to have you in the studio to play it for us today. We knew. Thank you for having me as friends, and this wonderful song keeps going.
他们想听这首歌。这真是，多么棒的礼物，多么棒的礼物。好歌，克里德。我们非常幸运能请你来到录音室今天为我们演奏它。我们懂的。谢谢你们邀请我这个朋友，这首美妙的歌会一直传唱下去。
And I knew the song was beautiful when I wrote it, but with the double whammy of being in our show, it's just taken on this mojo that's undeniable. Yeah. The Office fans are the best. They are. They are. Well, thanks for coming here before you leave on your tour
当我写这首歌的时候，我就知道它很美，但加上在我们剧中播放的双重威力，它就产生了一种不可否认的魔力。《办公室》的粉丝是最好的。他们真的是。真的。好吧，谢谢你在踏上巡演之前来到这里
so that we could hear it live. Well, thank you for having me. I don't get the tissues. I know. There's no tissues. Seriously, I want to pause and get tissues. And then Creed's going to play All the Faces. Oh, All the Faces, take one. I saw a friend today, it had been a while And we forgot each other's names But it didn't matter, cause deep inside
好让我们能现场听到它。好吧，谢谢你们邀请我。我可不能拿纸巾。我知道。没有纸巾。说真的，我想停下来拿点纸巾。然后克里德要演奏《所有的面孔》。哦，《所有的面孔》，第一条。我今天看到一个朋友，已经有一段时间没见了 我们忘了彼此的名字 但这没关系，因为在内心深处
The feelings still remain the same We talked of knowing one before you've met And how you feel more than you see And other worlds that lie in spaces in between And angels we can see There are the worlds that lie in spaces in between And angels we can see And all the faces that I know Have that same familiar glow
那种感觉依然如初 我们谈起在相遇之前就仿佛认识对方 感觉比看到的还要真切 还有存在于其间空隙中的其他世界 还有我们能看得见的 天使 存在于其间空隙中的世界 还有我们能看得见的 天使 我认识的所有面孔 都带着同样熟悉的容光
I think I must have known them somewhere once before But where, when, I don't know And all the faces we see each and every day When we get home at night, there's one face we need And when my mind's absorbed on my private little screen And I'm walking blind through a sea of unknown men I hear a voice reminding me there across the street Walks an old forgotten friend And we don't have to say a word
我想我以前一定在某处见过他们 但在哪里，什么时候，我不知道 我们每天看到的每一面面孔 当我们夜晚回到家里，有一张面孔是我们所需要的 当我的思绪沉浸在我私密的微小屏幕上 当我在茫茫陌生人海中盲目地行走 我听到一个声音提醒我，就在街的那头 走过来一个被遗忘的老朋友 我们甚至不用说一句话
It's really better left unsaid Just light through eyes that recognize All the faces that I know All the faces that I know And all the faces we see each and every day When we get home at night There's one face we need And all the faces I see each and every day
有些话不说出来其实更好 只有通过那些能够认出彼此的眼睛 我认识的所有面孔 我认识的所有面孔 我们每天看到的每一面面孔 当我们夜晚回到家里 有一张面孔是我们所需要的 我每天看到的每一面面孔
When I get home at night I'm teaching every day When I get home at night You're the face I need When I get home at night You're the only face I need. I need. Yay! Wow. That was awesome. Creed, mic drop. Creed, mic drop.
当我夜晚回到家里 我每天都在教导 当我夜晚回到家里 你是我需要的面孔 当我夜晚回到家里 你是我唯一的面孔 我需要的。我需要。耶！哇。太棒了。克里德，扔麦。克里德，扔麦。
Gotta give you a hug. I got so into it, I can't remember if I sang the last verse. It sounded like the complete song. I think it was perfect, Kree. I was getting emotional. I had to look away from you girls because you were so good. Kree, thank you so much. I love you girls. Well, that was just the greatest thing ever.
得给你个拥抱。我太投入了，记不清自己有没有唱最后一段。听起来像是一首完整的歌。我觉得太完美了，克里德。我当时都开始感动了。我不得不把视线从你们这些女孩身上移开，因为你们太棒了。克里德，非常感谢你。我爱你们，女孩们。好吧，那真的是有史以来最棒的事情。
You know, when you're in a moment and you know it's special and you're just like, I don't want to forget this. Yeah. Yeah. Well, everyone, we always end our episodes with thank yous because this podcast really is a collaboration, just like The Office was. And for this episode, we want to give a very big thank you to Steve Burgess and Dave Rogers for helping us with all of our finale facts.
你知道，当你身处一个时刻，你知道它是特别的，而你只会想：我不想忘记这个。对。对。好吧，各位，我们总是以致谢来结束我们的单集，因为这个播客确实是一次合作，就像《办公室》一样。对于这一集，我们要非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯和戴夫·罗杰斯帮助我们收集了所有大结局的冷知识。
But we also have to thank all of our cast, our directors, our writers, our crew members, Greg Daniels, everybody who came on the pod and answered our text messages and weird emails over these past five years. There were many. So many. So many.
但我们还要感谢所有的演员、导演、编剧、剧组成员、格雷格·丹尼尔斯，以及过去五年里所有来到播客、回复我们短信和古怪电子邮件的每个人。有好多人。非常多。非常多。
I also wanna just thank our Office family for texting us and emailing us words of encouragement as we went along, when they would hear an episode, if something meant something to them that we shared, it just kept us going, it meant so much. And I wanna thank you guys who are listening and who've been there with us from the beginning and you sent in amazing fan questions
我还想感谢我们的《办公室》大家庭，在我们录制的过程中给我们发短信、发邮件鼓励我们，当他们听到某集播客，如果我们分享的内容对他们有所触动，这就会一直支撑着我们，意义重大。我想感谢你们这些收听节目并从一开始就陪伴着我们的听众，你们发来了精彩的粉丝问题
and background catches and bullsh** cards and you have helped make this podcast what it is. We're so thankful. We also want to thank our office ladies team, especially Sam, Ainsley, Ileana, and Cassie. In fact, I'd like to give a special mention to Cassie here. Cassie, I feel like you really are the unsung hero of our team. Everyone, she does so much behind the scenes to make this show each week.
以及背景彩蛋和胡扯卡片，你们帮助这个播客成为了现在的样子。我们非常感激。我们还要感谢我们的“办公室女士”团队，尤其是萨姆、安斯利、伊莱亚娜和卡茜。事实上，我要在这里特别提一下卡茜。卡茜，我觉得你真的是我们团队幕后的无名英雄。各位，为了每周制作这个节目，她在幕后付出了太多。
She helps us creatively. She edits the show. We really couldn't do it without you, Cassie. I mean, the only reason that we were able to transition from one company to another in the middle of our rewatch with everything that I have had going on personally this year was because you took such good care of us, and so thank you, Cassie.
她在创意上帮助我们。她剪辑节目。没有你，我们真的做不到，卡茜。我的意思是，今年我个人经历了很多事情，我们之所以能够在重温节目的中途从一家公司平稳过渡到另一家公司，纯粹是因为你把我们照顾得这么好，所以谢谢你，卡茜。
Thank you, Cassie. Of course, it's been my pleasure. And of course, you guys know that Sam is the other person here with us each week. It meant so much to us to have Sam back to finish the rewatch, but we have some really exciting news to share with everyone. Sam is going to stay on with us for Office Ladies 6.0! We could not be more excited. We have our team. I'm so thankful. Second breakfast for everyone. Second breakfast. And Office Lady 6.0 starts next week. No breaks.
谢谢你，卡茜。当然，这是我的荣幸。当然，你们知道萨姆是每周和我们在一起的另一个人。萨姆能回来和我们一起完成重温之旅，这对我们意义重大，但我们有一些非常激动人心的好消息要和大家分享。萨姆将继续留在我们身边制作《办公室女士》6.0！我们太激动了。我们有我们的团队了。我太感激了。大家的第二份早餐。第二份早餐。《办公室女士》6.0将于下周开始。没有休息。
We are diving right in. Next Wednesday we will be here talking with casting director Alison Jones. She was number one on the list of someone we wanted to talk to. It's a fantastic interview. We love you guys so much. We will see you next week. Sam, Cassie, I think we all need to say at the same time, we did it.
我们直接切入正题。下周三我们将在这里与选角导演艾莉森·琼斯交谈。她是我们要交谈的人名单上的头号人物。这是一次非常棒的采访。我们太爱你们了。我们下周见。萨姆、卡茜，我想我们都需要同时说出那句话，我们做到了。
One, two, three. We did it. See you next week! See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
一，二，三。我们做到了。下周见！回头见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡茜·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是安斯利·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. rotten. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡树》。烂。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。